y est d'avoir les caméras ont déjà gens
voient leur aide on va on va on va on va
se placer
donc là c'est la table en fait on n'a
que trois caméras donc ça c'est
important de le savoir si maxime ne joue
plus de en tête on n'aura plus les
parties donc là c'était caméra un
la caméra deux escales fonctionne
à
je ne sais pas si elle fonctionne
non fonctionne pas s'ils fonctionnent
donc ça c'est la caméra de maxime voilà
et l'échiquier
on va le gérer
on va le mettre un peu comme ça
voilà et ben voilà on est bien
parfait on à la caméra elle est bien on
abat on a tous là non
on a tous
joueur en masse qu'on aime vlc écrit en
gros on à l'échiquier on a tout ce qu'il
nous faut on a plus qu'à attendre les
coûts de sa chique et riant bizarre la
prépa de sachy quirion quand même quand
on y pense parce qu'il a fait le fou des
trois assez vite j'ai si c'était le coup
mais hélas il réfléchit
ouais et on a le fonds vert
on est parfait on a plus qu'à attendre
les coûts maintenant
c'est bizarre quand même d'avoir joué le
fou détroit qui est pas un coût mais du
tout et réfléchir au temps après j'ai
six trouve ça quand même assez étonnant
prisunic jamais à côté des noms des
joueurs on le sait qu'ils sont j'aime
dans ce tournoi
ah ah
[Musique]
pourquoi pas en fait un
c'est quand même un titre honorifique
sachez client
lui-même de sa prépa ouais c'est un peu
étonnant quand même parce que tu as
l'impression qu'il est rentré avec
conviction là-dedans maxime il a déjà
joué cette même variante à plusieurs
reprises suis dit qu'il est bien préparé
lui aussi est à l'impression que c'est
lui qui se fait sortir en premier de sa
prépa mais après comme je le disais
l'écart de niveau est tellement énorme
entre un sachet qui rien 26 41 et un
maxima 27 70 il ya un gouffre
peut-être finir la prépa il a quand même
vraiment tout jouer tempo non il semble
pas et 130 points l'eau à ce niveau là
c'est un gouffre un
peu cher je tiens un petit alors il ya
deux over leccese comme nacho il y en a
un avec une toute petite caméra aps de
la salle comme la mienne maintenant un
tout petit peu plus grande
et l'échiquier en grand ou il ya un
deuxième
la deuxième option la deuxième
possibilité c'est la grande caméra
et le petit échiquier
vu les sacrifices faits pour avoir les
caméras j'ai envie de te dire c'est pas
pour la mettons petit tu vois
c'est pour à m si comme moi et qu'on
voit pas du tout
on va fait que c'est un petit peu vrai
mais c'est plus tu en as
on a voulu les caméras ont les uns
cette façon il se passe rien sur
l'échiquier si on a besoin il y aura une
vision avec un avec un échiquier plus
grand mais là quand même on se met un
peu la cam de toute façon y'a rien à
dire sur la position soit il se rappelle
soit il se rappelle pas un
là
euh
démontré le truc qui paraissait logique
d'envoi il sait quoi trop maintenant
avec le cavalier f400 on en a déjà parlé
sachez qu'un qui est en train de ramer
contre la veste de max havart imaginer
contre mvsc s'arrête
mais au moins on en profite un petit peu
on les a pas eu depuis le début
on les met un peu en grand enfin c'est
quand même une unique plus value des
caméras cd m en grand kouassi en plus
déjà qu'on voit pas grand chose et que
c'est pas mes gains intéressants si en
plus on l'aimé en petit ça sert vraiment
plus à rien
il envoie sa chique irions issue
complètement ça sent la victoire du
ministre aujourd'hui
un issue
il sut complètement chiant mais ça
marche un retour
ça marche de folie quand même
un ministre ambulants qui passe
voilà le ministre est là hein
pourquoi me le ministre il n'est pas un
masque ffp2 d'ailleurs
quitte à mettre un masque non-stop et
pourrait à
ces terribles regardez physiquement le
langage corporel des deux joueurs
regardez le ministre
chemise beau gosse installé sur
l'échiquier le dos droit
il fait il fait 20 centimètres de plus
regardez ça chie quirion
sa chique et riant
en sueur les requins ne sont pas
végétalien malheureusement c'est dommage
il aurait pu tirer une petite gros
bras ya même une différence de taille
quand même assez assez imposante un
sachet qui rend c'est un peu le jason
burton quoi il a quarante piges tu as
l'impression qu'ils qui retourne en
enfance et mais maxime qui va repartir
au c'est terrible de faire ça oh c'est
terrible il est juste venu vérifier
maternelle il est en train de se faire
maternelle d'
frôla la caisse qu'il n'est pas bien
sache écrire en
say plus haché qui rend ces chasses achi
qui rentrent en inde les amis
il est en train déjà de réfléchir à ces
connexions pour
le vol pour délit et ce qui passe par
moscou et ce qui passe par dubaï
enfin ces châssis qui rend 3 c'est
terrible
il est pas il est pas bien
or il en train de se dire ma prépa de ce
matin elle était vraiment vraiment
inutile
enfin ça il se le dit en anglais
sûrement mais en train de se dire les
frérots le jour de repos
j'aurais mieux fait des temps de ph
terrible
arena il est pas bien il n'est pas bien
gros maximum qui viennent pour la came
c'est n'importe quoi
grâce à shaw tour c'est insupportable il
est insupportable le ministre
c'est terrible il sait pas pourquoi il
est là
pourquoi j'ai marqué autant de points en
début de tournoi pourquoi je joue table
de il serait peut-être mieux table table
25 et il fait fou 4
prend le bluffeur du dimanche
jean michel bluff il avait le premier
coup de l'ordi le frérot aux seychelles
de faire ça oh ça c'est sean o ça c'est
très très chaud
la casita avait l'impression qu'ils
allaient sortir un panier de roses pour
en vendre aux joueurs et aux joueuses et
là tout d'un coup il sort première ligne
de l'ordi le frérot
oh ça ça va pas ça fait pas plaisir côté
indien
prend le bâtard fois n'y a pas d'autre
mot roland foire et on croirait on
croyait qu'il était plus dans sa prépa
en fait il se rappeler de tous
olemps foiré et maintenant ils tournent
autour de l'échiquier avec sa petite
tête de remémorisation des lignes faux
france a dans ta gueule dams et 7 tempo
au c'est magnifique magnifique
prends ça dans ta gueule il connaissait
le ministre pro c'est magnifique dams et
7 tempo or c'est pas de bol ça chie
quirion
sa chique issue
rocé magnifique là ce que vient de faire
maxime
où il n'est pas bien il est pas bien ton
petit coup de bluff n'a pas marché
frérot dames c'est cette tempo et là ça
va se lever côté maxime et oui et oui et
oui trop ça fait tellement mal dames
c'est cette île est pas bien il est pas
bien l'indien
il est dans le dur en
trop il est dans le dur le frérot
son petit coup de bluff le manège n'a
pas duré très longtemps dix secondes
après dams et 7 dans ta gueule revient à
soir je repars magnifique au magnifique
trop tellement pas bien la
voilà ses tacles à la jugulaire ouais
il est pas bien où il répond tempo
l'enfoiré c'est bien joué c'est bien
joué il se laisse pas marcher dessus
ça prouve que c'était un groupe et il se
lève au sahara pas plaire à maxime oh ça
ça va pas plaire à maxime
paul fort il a fait dam des trois tempo
derrière
il est là mais maxime se rappelle de
tout team autour de 8 magnifique
magnifique
et oui femmes des trois étaient dans
leur haine gens là c'est terrible pour
sa chérie en maxime se rappelle de tout
hossa a travaillé côté côté ministériel
première ligne contre première ligne
magnifique
et ça repart
bon là ils sont toujours dans la
préparer il est 13h45 45 minutes de jeu
et les deux joueurs sont encore dans la
théorie en tout cas pour eux
mais j'ai l'impression que maximal
dessus quand même là ça chie quirion il
est pas il est pas sûr de lui
il est pas bien le frérot
il est pas frérot indien
bon il joue bien mais
mais il est tombé sur un os et quand on
parle dos on sait très bien duquel on
parle
même envie de dire il est tombé sur un
muscle
comment est ce qui va et quand les mecs
qui va nous la jouer
ça chie well et il est pas bien il est
pas bien il est pas bien
il va pas se rappeler
pas se rappeler
ça marche un peu autour
c'est terrible
bonfol à la question c'est je pense
qu'il a quand même un visage de
quelqu'un qui essaye de se rappeler ou
qui encore dans sa mémoire plus que dans
la réflexion dans le calcul
dégoûté savoir lé d'aig la lydec parce
qu'il avait son petit feu quatre dames
détroit ils pissent pensait être
intelligent et finalement il ses
premières lignes d'un
well as c'est dire si ça rentre dans une
position qui joue il est nettement moins
fort que maxime dans ce type de position
l'écart de niveau va être très sévère
pour sa chique errants maxime peut la
gagner aujourd'hui il peut la perdre
encore 1 là tout est possible et 3
résultats sont sur l'habitat
mais pour le moment c'est une ouverture
de rêve que nous sort maxime
c'est terrible il ya un arbitre a
derrière qui vient un peu gâcher la la
teuf assez bien les se laisse marcher
maxime vas-y vas-y vas-y par par par
part
il gênait marcy maxime sur le tapis de
marche
terrible ça
voilà voilà c'est ça qu'on aime maxime
qui revient à leur vide qui le suit on
croirait pacman ces genres de fantômes
dans pacman larbitre si maxime mange une
vitamine il peut le bouffer il peut le
bouffer attention les amis maxime peu
beauf l arbitre autour
ça peut être terrible aussi pêché une
vitamine c terrible pour les arbitres
moi je pense qu'ils vont revenir tous
les deux
si marc maxime revient seul sait que
l'arbitré s'est fait bouffer
très très clairement si rabbit ne
revient pas c'est que maxime la bouffe
et
non là il est il est pas bien l'arbitré
à mon avis d'ailleurs maxime il et ça
fait déjà émis qui revient pas à mon
avis à du grabuge là bas un petit peu un
petit peu plus loin sur la droite
elle n'allait pas bien mon avis ils
arbitrent
vote quelque chose sous la table ça chie
quirion
c'est vrai
peut-être mieux vaut-il ne pas savoir
quoi
donc là
réfléchis je pense que maxime devrait
mettre du jal avant de toucher les
pièces blanches
si je puis me permettre
mon avis important
important
ça réfléchit un côté hachikian
ne vaut mieux ne pas deux pièces pour le
moment et je pense aussi attention ça va
jouer il n'est pas sûr de lui il est pas
serein il est pas serein
krishnan
d'ailleurs attention 1,6 à shiki rampe
se met à rigoler il peut évoluer en a ri
krishna
donc attention et à son évolution ne
s'est peu plus loin dans le tournoi
un peu comme les pokémon
il faut se méfier
des jolies c'était une blague très
technique c'est là
je pense pas qu'ils calculent je pense
qu'ils se rappellent encore en vrai
il n'est pas bien il n'est pas bien
fabien jardin c'est qu'ils en veste
rouge
et un pop up ça dégage voilà c'est bien
la laisser nous laisser nous les deux
gladiateurs
bon après cette position là ça ça
traduit généralement
un peu de stress mais pas forcément
d'inquiétude
maxime qui marchent à fond ma
question c'est qu'il fera le premier
niveau mémoire ouais après le truc c'est
que maxime il n'a pas besoin de la
mémoire pour bien jouer ce qui n'est pas
forcément le cas de son homologue indien
oh ça revient avec un fait qu'a sa
vient poser les boissons chaudes ou le
petit est assez terrible
maxime il fait un livre à ribéry pendant
que pendant krishna ne réfléchis
important
il continue ce travail de livreurs livre
alpha échec
et là il fait il fait un peu de deux
piges délit verrou
résout bas café au café au carnaval
bien
ce qui est réfléchie là
ça doit être 1 quand même beaucoup sinon
le reste fait pas trop sens à vrai dire
elle ce serait beau que maxime hygiène
avec une chicha ce serait magnifique ça
a bien joué le chat ce serait énorme
maxime qui vient avec du charbon qui se
fait une chicha et qui fume pendant la
partie serait exceptionnel ça ce serait
exceptionnel c'est pas possible
ça ce serait du jamais vu en fait
maxime qui revient avec la petite chicha
portables qui posent sur la table oh
ça ce serait extraordinaire
un petit bar
gaza côté serait magnifique qui pose le
barbecue à côté qui fait les merguez qui
fument la chicha ce serait
extraordinaire
à ce serait vraiment magnifique
j'imagine tour au maximum revenir en
djellaba t'imagines babouche djellaba
maxime qui revient la chicha xv à fumer
tranquille avec un cac qui vire à
l'aider pour
pour le charmant au dessus comme ça ce
serait magnifique tabacchi qui passe qui
vient mettre le charbon qui soufflent un
peu dans la la chicha pour pour enlever
la fumée ce serait exceptionnel
ce serait exceptionnel
thaci savoir vingt cas qui fait
ça ce serait vraiment exceptionnel
j babouche sur la table mais
ça ce serait incroyable
ça ce serait vraiment incroyable
la maxime qui sera sciée
qui connaissait il répond thème pour une
nouvelle fois
il a joué fois elle fit je crois
il est insupportable
voilà le truc c'est qui qui se rappelle
bien maxime connaissant un peu le
loustic quand il fait ça c'est qu'ils se
rappellent de tout
ça chie 40 qui se rappelle aussi
ok là il est plus sûr à 100% il enlève
le badge ans qu'elle ait peut-être
qu'ils se rappellent un peu mais ça y
est c'est la première fois que maxime va
réfléchir dans cette partie
oh bah oui laurent à peu prendre le thé
c'était prévu un banc bien sûr c'était
prévu c'était prévu la petite boisson
qui ne demande plus pourquoi une belle
continue à jouer a dit siliana bah oui
il y avait même calculé le café en amont
et oui le café ans benoît était là
pourquoi maxime à la même chaise que ça
file à ces jeux sans maxime en confiance
ici
bon alors c'est quoi les options pour
maxime d'ailleurs
déjà yahoo g7 inquiet logique ayant de
faire flouer fui de fous j'ai cette
cavale et f4 pour taper
ça c'est pou logique
deuxième
cavalier f4 à vrai dire
a quoi sert il en fait est qu'il a pas
bluffer peut-être qu'il arrivait pas
bien se rappeler sa chique et riant
6 5 c'est un coup faut connaître sinon
ça paraît un peu
celui contre sens
aujourd'hui s'est infligé cette 2e à 5 3
me faisait sept ans fait ça paraît
tellement logique et cavalières quatre
erreurs
f4 même logique que ce soit une erreur
puisque ça donne fou prend puis on prend
et h5 ses comptes vu qu'il a fait h 4 ça
sert plus à rien de bouge et le cavalier
pour le moment faut mieux le préparer
on leur demande de garder les masques le
masque que tu dois le garder quand tu te
lèves je crois
ce que contrairement aux sports comme le
basket ou quoi là il ya il ya plus de
250 joueurs dans la salle donc il s'est
un peu le même système que quand tu veux
en resto en fait
tu mets ton masque lorsque tu te
déplaces dans la dans la salle
je crois que c'est ça la règle après
faut il confirmer là c'est un petit peu
spéciale lui qui un confinement les
thoniers hommes en même temps
maxime qui le remet à chaque fois
après ça le dérange peut être pas du
tout hein
juste crois je suis un roi à schwyz
qu'est ce que veulent les blancs et
c'est une bonne question
je pense tour c'est un c4 quand même
mais bon
un filtre otage des 6 mai décision
pouvait refuser cette et on pourra
mettre une tour en des 8
ce cavalier j'ai travaillé j'ai trois
cavaliers 5 en fait tu veux aller ch 5
bon on pas trop réfléchir la position
jusqu'à maintenant on attendait de
sortir de l'ouverture ses positions
toujours très bizarre
on a un pion de plus avec les noirs
quand même
vous insistez sur une attaque vers le
roi blanc mais ça c'est normal on est en
reco poser
après le problème des noirs c'est qu'on
a un peu vissé sur case blanche en fait
donc les pions là ils sont pas très
mobile le fou il a beaucoup de liberté
et des blocs bien
sert à quoi h 4 h 4 ça sert à anticiper
le déplacement du cavalier pour faire h5
et peut-être dans certaines variantes ça
protège le pion
bien elle est bonne je pense que
juste à vau-l'eau kitty nom facile et
dangereux
je n'ai pas mes lordi aime pas trop et
la position inverse dégueulasse mais les
bonnes ça se voit qu'il n'est pas en
forme et karakar one a en fait ça peut
être un adversaire
c'est bien c'est par vaux d'appariement
c'est un jeune qui vous super bien qui a
fait premier ex-aequo aux championnats
des états unis
caruana il a un peu en méforme et en
plus il n'a pas de bol
et fier où est-ce qu'on peut jeter un
oeil
aux djadja
il est la fille roues ils ont l'air plus
petit que maxime dans tous
ces mois
plus petit nom
attendez et en problème avec l'échiquier
contre nager
ya déjà perdu pas mal de temps ménage et
il est bien préparé il est connu pour
être un excellent second temps
pas mas queen ils n'ont pas de masque
mais à je pense pas que ce soit
obligatoire à la table
on est sûr maxime qui a joué
et qui envoie ira simcoe
donc deuxième coupe la turbine mais il
connaît un c'est sûr à 5 c'est pas genre
de couple qui joue sans connaître il
connaît encore maxime
profondeur 45 ans mais il connaît et
c'est sûr
qu'à 5 sur dame prend des 5 c'est tout
bête ans et s'ouvrir la colonne b pour
attaquer et on voit bien que le fou
angers7 il va être super fort parce
qu'il défendra le rock et il attaquera
le rock adverse
français de là mais je veux juste
expliquer l'idée globale
de laisser le plomb et adam français 2
mais globalement ce pion en fait tu t'en
fous généralement on lie adam français
de aussi mais globalement tu t'en fous
de donner ça et tu veux au contraire toi
ouvrir le truc avec un 4b 4 et b3 ou à
trois
ça paraît un peu long visuellement
mais le truc je pense qui connaît encore
c'est que je pense qui connaît encore
max
maman était à un deux
trois coups peut-être je peux même faire
à 4 à 3 à vrai dire
pour ouvrir
non
c'est après la question c'est surtout
comment les blancs progresse ce qu'on
arrête les blancs ils ont une belle
position en soit pas le fou en dessin
qui contrôle les cases
et qui tape
donc ça c'est cool pour eux ce cavalier
h5 qui peut plus vraiment revenir parce
que tu peux pas te permettre de laisser
h5 on va être les noirs leur seul plan
pour le moment à vrai dire c'est un peu
d'envoyer les punto de ce côté affaiblir
un peu le roi est peut-être un jour
faire fou g74 et jouer les cases noires
mais actuellement
je n'en ai pas de
ces trois et un coup l'idée c'est sur b4
faire ces quatre peut-être
serrez pas trop parce qu'on a on
pourrait se faire trop affaiblir les
cases noires mais peut-être on peut
utiliser une idée très thématiques puis
on prend qui on prend et oursins
l'idée c'est un peu de nettoyer les
tours de l'échiquier mais éventuellement
bon pas forcément comme ça mais c'est
pour imager c'est d'enlever toutes les
tours
et se dire que bon disons qu'à relief 4
fou prend pions tant que les noms aaron
un pion de plus mais qu' ils ont
beaucoup de mal à venir se mobiliser à
l'ale dames et que le fou c'est vraiment
une tour de contrôle il contrôle
beaucoup de casse proche du roi adverse
proche de son roi et proches aussi ma il
va aider à la promotion des pions
donc du coup peut-être que ces trois
avec l'idée sur b4 de prendre et ours et
1 et sur 1 4 de jouer à trois
pour geler l
aile dame
ces trois sapeurs pas qu'on en fait
et du coup sur ces 4 bon là on peut
juste prendre en fait et surtour c1
le truc c'est que tour séance et dans
l'idée de jouer ces quatre mais les
blancs ils auraient pu le jouer il ya
longtemps ce c4
qu'est-ce qui fait ça c'est un arbitre
lycée qui se met devant des caméras
comme ça bon si c'est maxime ça passe
mais c'est quand même incroyable ça
vu ça jamais
betrand
je crois qu'on sait faire arbitre aide
à tours c'est un c4 ça va dans ce plan
là mais mon de façon on pourra sur ces
cas de faire des 4
donc ça a pas l'air de trop passer à
vrai dire
moi j'aime bien ces trois bizarrement
mais
n'empêche b4 sur à 4 tu fais à 3 tu
bloques mais après j'ai pas de plans
pour attaquer par contre
ces trois sur ton ouais moi c'était pas
le coût de leur disent être
la petite turbine était plutôt sûr tour
c'est en fait mes tours saint gemme pas
passive a joué sa chute ayant
non mais tour c'est en fait c'est 4 b 4
ces quatre b 4 après les cases noires
ouais bon après jouable aussi un
façon si ses recommandations à turbine
c'est que c'est jouable
mais je préfère ces trois personnes
bref c'est une position bizarre parce
que les deux joueurs semblent avoir
beaucoup de jeu mais ils ont pas
vraiment où attaquer
ses traits même pas à cause de dan 17
il veut croire maintenant si j'en suis
comme moi
j'arrive pas à trouver de plan pour les
blancs
c'est pas facile trouve un plan pour les
blancs bizarrement par l'ambiance et les
blancs qui ont de jeu mais n'arrive pas
à comprendre où perçaient parce que
f4 t'as pas vraiment envie
ça va échanger ouvrir le fou j'ai 7
h 5 qui arrive pas
ce pacte a pas envie c'est que tu peux
pas
ces quatre on a vu qu'il y avait les b 4
à 4 à 3 et ça va tu as fait bien encore
plus sur case noire
donc en vrai après qu'est notre site a
pas vraiment de plan mais bon un avion
plus
c'est à dire que typiquement sur réussi
à faire un d'amd cette dame d'hesdin f5
mais changer les dames quoi tu peux
jouer le lien avec ton pions plus un
jour ou l'autre
gekko dans le son
alors ça c'est pas normal
norbu ça c'est pas normal
il n'est pas sensé existait
mais c'est peut-être que là peut-être
lot de twitch
fenêtres deux fois ouverte ouais
bon ça réfléchit des sur l'autre
français
je me trompe pas ce que je tiens on voit
un peu tout
ça passe depuis
et pour vouloir aujourd'hui je sais pas
mais dans le tournoi où il a deux points
et demi
il a deux points et demi sera
sur six donc il est hors course
mais saatchi quirion jeu et pour lui
et si pnk pas trop mal constitue un vrai
si pnk faudra y faire attention ça peut
être un joueur très dangereux pour la
suite
et si bienne cas c'est un joueur qui
peut qui peut revenir et qui peut poser
des problèmes
genre de joueur qu'il faudrait mieux
jouer avec les blancs en fait
juste son métallique
écoute c'est pas censé être le cas
ce n'est pas censé être le cas
microcrédit 1 normalement non mais après
quand je parle trop fort même ça ça peut
ça ça peut arriver quand je parle trop
fort
on est sur czech com ou
au l'oubli yade à des pubs aux
magnifiques trois minutes de pub qui
partent aux os
os mais ces manifs ça
amélie on avait oublié
abat trois minutes hein
ah bah oui quand même
on souffle un
et là souffle à 1
je ne suis plus je ne voyais plus la
chaîne victimes de connecter
assisté connectés project
riboud
c est terrible
tout cela non non c'est des pubs
individuel malheureusement
bon on a plus qu'à attendre 1
c'est un peu long à temps et déjà 1h20
de jeu il se passe pas mal de choses ça
chie qui réfléchit quand même beaucoup
c'est beau les petites pubs
des pubs mètres bien
si un bail normalement non non sur une
chaise comme
monde invitait
salue ici ou là
bon là on est un peu dans le dans le
temps mort de la partie entre guillemets
complexe
ce post it war
temmar ouais je peux le faire passer en
rapide de toute façon hier
enfin le temps mort ça fait une heure et
quart dur en fait on est sorti de la
théorie avant le a5 et sajoo lentement
il ajouté quoi il a joué ses trois ou c4
on va voir on va laisser la partie se
rejouer
à jouer le c3 ray que je pensais aussi
en m
on marche marche comme ça ils essaient
de faire le vide pour se reposer
détruire bien une pense à mort à la
position a normalement ils pensent à la
position
ouais c'est un coup très logique hein ça
comme on disait est sur b4 on veut
échanger jouer la colonne c'est
est sûre à quatre on veut faire à trois
pour faire un blocus
il propose toujours des limites qui peut
être logique pour faire b 4
dames
être un autre cours est tombé huit dames
17 ces deux coups très logique
assez avec le masque comme ça pour
quelqu'un qui porte des lunettes ça peut
être un peu pénible je n'ai pas j'avais
pas pensé à ça sous cet angle ça peut
faire de la buée
surtout que c'est pas obligatoire donc
il pourrait ne pas le porter
et il sait encore ce qui va faire ses 3
c dans son règne il va jouer assez vite
là
j'ai pas vu je regardais pas là qu'à un
moment
il n'a pas joué on est d'accord
il a eu envie je pense que ces trois
c'était un coup tellement logique que
c'est ce à quoi il pensait quand il se
baladait
et un petit poussière qui le gêne
tout cas ça se regarde ou trop dangereux
disons qu'il a fait hk train peut pour
empêcher cavale et f4 pour faire h5
rapidement donc là le cavalier il semble
quand même bien placé 1
je pense qu'il a déjà des sites et son
coût
doit être dame 17 ça lui donne tête des
dames f5 dans l' orange
mais
[Musique]
mais il termine sa réflexion quoi
papiers pendant une partie non
bon
sim qui a réfléchi
charon contades de
s'attendre à autre chose comme un frérot
ben on va voir comment quand ça joue
surtout là aujourd'hui a pas grand chose
à dire
une partie tactique et on peut expliquer
les enjeux mais au delà de ça c'est que
des coûts concret
il ya beaucoup de possibilités et les
coûts se valent à peu près
ça peut faire un jour de statut quo un
peu bizarre
ça peut genre de statu quo bizarre
il a joué comme on l'appelle jean dame
17 ans je crois
la dame est décalé village aux dames 17
way assez logique
cette dame sur la case sur la colonne
cei faisaient plus grand chose elle
pouvait même être exposés lorsqu'on
faisait des échanges elle peut repartir
en f5 pour échanger les dames on a quand
même un pion de plus
c'est bizarre n'est pas facile a
progressé pour les deux c'est ça ouais
protège mais 1 co 6 way la dame est
juste globalement mieux place en 17 à
présent
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
pour les deux joueurs
mais avec les normes on al'avantage du
pion
lui c'est quand même assez important
on l'appelait cases blanches soient les
mieux placés
lis quoi
ben il doit viser
la prise d'un carénage 5 1
et ses positions très étrange ray
cette vitesse quattro amev quattro
j'ai besoin que maxime yvan il va faire
fou g7 il va préparer cavaliers f4 des
quartiers voit plus comment maxime peut
continuer
f4 c'est vous apparaît vraiment
tellement dur à jouer
après c'est sûr je fais tour des f1 a
aimé jacquet g3 se fait tour à chef
bouger cette f4
et puis on prend en échange tout tu
prends de la tour et de seuils de taper
f7 way peut-être c'est jouable
j'ai cette f4
mais bon il ya cavaliers j'ai trois
quarts et des f-5 qui va arriver il ya
même 4 ici qu elle jouable vous prend et
cavalli g3
ça sera visuellement ça passe jamais en
fait
et c'est ça le problème des blancs c'est
qu'en fait rien faire avec les noirs ça
semble plus simple
parce que tu as le pion de plus
j'ai l'impression qu'elle est chiante à
jouer avec les vins patiente mais elle
est vraiment pas vraiment pas aller dans
la bonne prépa sa chique et riant
il a voulu surprendre maxime mais en
réalité maxime était très près sur cette
variante là
et du coup il est vraiment dans le dur
et en plus vu à la vitesse à laquelle
joue maxime ce qu'il a dû sentir il a dû
réviser quelque chose dans ce raid jeu
là
et c'est lyon qui clôturait sévillan
s'est vraiment pas un joueur sain plein
alors clutch peut-être pas mais mais oui
la position est très tendue
c'est loin d'elle clair qu'avec les
blancs fabiano soit mieux
mais c'est bien clairement à 26,54 c'est
pas un bon appariement
joueur difficile c'est bien
mais c'est le poème de son assez que
maxime avec un demi point de plus que
caruana y joue quelqu'un de réellement
plus faible alors nettement plus faibles
je sais pas mais plus très clairement
plus faibles
c'est pas parce que tu as plus de points
qu'il faut des joueurs plus forts en
fait
on les vins une nouvelle fois encore
dans le dur
et ou déjà et firent au jaï firoud déjà
bon
ça âge où on est sortis de l'ouverture
les blancs ont le pion au sein qui peut
peut-être un jour être accompagné par f4
f5 même si ça paraît encore loin
tu as quand même un avantage des espaces
davantage de développement tu as des
qualités 4 france 5 qui peuvent traîner
aussi
après 2006 26,56 euros gagnés caruana
ouais mais il a perdu contre evian
il ya deux semaines de ça aux
championnats des états unis du coup au
niveau
impact psychologique
assez vian est forcément en confiance
même s'il sait qu'à roanne est fort que
lui comme tu as gagné une partie contre
ce même joueur yahia peux tu as moins
d'impact psychologique la position est
bonne non caruana il peut être dans le
dur lacie maxime gagné alireza si maxime
alireza gagne aujourd'hui font un break
énorme
le danger viendra peut-être des scipione
caedhu bof plus que de karwan à mon avis
surtout que maxime là il a une position
aujourd'hui c'est la première position
avec les noirs
où il peut peut-être se passer quelque
chose on fera que sa chique ya rien en
face des erreurs mais mais c'est une
position il peut en faire
mais savez giroud gagnent ils se
prennent les plus forts qui ont un demi
point de moins
ouais oui
oui oui oui maintenant oui sur la fin du
tournoi oui mais les plus forts sera pas
forcément ceux qui ont le
plus des lots entre guillemets
en tout cas déjà tu auras pas caruana
heleven ça c'est sûr et après
chanteront peu de regarder les noms
médailles de toutes façons tu vas jouer
s'ils tiennent qu'à quoi qu'il se passe
s'ils gagnent
que t-55 et demi tu joueras dans tous
les cas et si pink a donc autant le
jouer avec cinq et demi 1
ils vont tenter devant surtout quand un
meilleur des partages site un demi point
devant et que tu fais est nul en fait
même si à des gens qui reviennent sur
toi et qui reviennent à égalité de
points tu seras quand même devant
majoration blanc contre issy piano
demain ça peut être fier round jackie le
prends aussi faudra voir
il faudra voir qui qui le joue
après les lots correspondant les matchs
enfin tout un tas de trucs à calculer
acheteurs poils de sa chute car on est
pas très positif après
tant qu'il joue les bons coups il vous
les bons coups mais il s'est embarqué
dans un truc là sa chique et riant
il s'est pas embarqué dans ce qui devait
s'embarquer
allaire
a l'air vraiment dur là pour le joueur
indien comme on l'a vu un c'est une
position n'y a pas vraiment de plan pour
les deux
en tout cas de plan facile et sans se
faire contrer et comme je vous disais
dans ses positions là au final celui qui
a un pion plus il va forcément avoir
plus d'idées parce que il peut essayer
de transposer dans une finale et
progresser petit à petit alors que quand
un pion de - bah
si la pollution elle fait des statu quo
normalement ton avantage d'une amie qui
se réduit petit à petit
on craque gagnant ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle aussi ouais bah c'est excellent
pour le départager les gagnants contre
eux qui
sont pas faciles à trouver sur ce truc
là
contre onitsuka et marron
ah oui on y touche à jouer sur che ce
cas
il est très bon blitz mais oui et pas
et c'est pas sérieux là ce qu'il a fait
avec les noirs
ouais ça les spectateurs y gagne
[Musique]
le départage maxime va vraiment être bon
à force déjà il joue devant et si en
plus les gars qui bat il remonte dans le
tournoi par la suite c'est magnifique
une corde
si benko sera dangereux c'est sûr
je veux qu'on sache ouais j'ai joué pas
mal de parties constatent chikhi ans
qui avait fini par me bloquait
trop de victoire du français
mancka sera dangereux mais devra jouer
siro elles veulent aussi dur pour l'ios
clairement
bon
plus ça réfléchit plus on prend aussi un
sur un peu chier mais d'un autre côté ça
nous arrange aussi hein parce que 44
minutes au bout d'un moment
si la position vient à se compliquer
compte dans les tactiques dans une
dizaine de coups et qui reste plus que
10 minutes à sachy ça peut le pousser à
l'erreur
ça craque chennai air est non alors ça
doit craqué
alors craque c'est vite dit mais
[Musique]
la position est belle pour fuir ou 1
les pièces sont quand même assez bien
placé
globalement
c'est blanc je censure des bonnes kg du
cahier qui peut allonger sinko
bon
plutôt bien pour les deux joueurs
français en réalité ici puisque fil
rouge avec les blancs à une position à
perspectives et maxime avec les noirs
à une position qui peut tourner à trois
résultats
là toute la difficulté avec les blancs
c'est vraiment de trouver un plan f4
c'est dur à faire marcher ne rien faire
n'est pas possible et la pollution est
réellement difficile à jouer
complexe
il va une fois de plus les blancs qu'un
nouvel dans le tournoi ouais vu qu'il a
joués rondins avec les blancs oui mais
après il fait à trois je crois
il fait le set-up auquel on avait pensé
coup ils optent
pour l'attentât fermeture de la dame
je pense qu'on peut mettre maintenant la
tour en b 8 pour essayer de faire un bep
cap quand même hein on va empêcher d
akkad dans certains wrench de fermeture
j'aime vraiment beaucoup tourbe et 8
b 8 avec l'idée de mettre le four g7 et
b 4
4 et vraiment ouvrir sur b2
après il peut à jouets poupées trois là
dessus et l'idée c'est que sur b4 on
peut faire pions champions prend et a4
et le fou couvre la casa 4 ça ce serait
bien joué tombé huit four b3
interdit
b46 intermittents un nombre ici j'aurais
dû jouer le thème des 7 ha ouais mais
avant
ici si on faisait tour des huit balles
n'avaient pas joué à troyes encore
et donc du coup et aux 1
à 3 sur tourbe et 8 four b3 ça paraît
vraiment être fort
sur intéressante de aix nice qui peut
jouer b4 avec les blancs sur trois huit
ça c'est une question très intéressante
c'est un coût qui est 18e allemand
extrêmement bizarre mais qui peut
parfois exister
pour en fait bloqué un peu plus haut et
se mettre le pion sous visu
et ab j'imagine ab
mais bon on va se faire attaquer sur sur
ces trois probablement
c'est dur
bekaert ça a l'air bien passé mais fou
et enfin sur tourbe et 8 poupée 3
vraiment l'air d'être un bon coup et si
les noirs font à 4 du coup on revient en
d5 éventuellement on vend à 2 je sais
pas mais hélas les noirs n'ont plus de
b4 on a réussi à consolider les cases
noires proche du rock et à annihiler un
peu la puissance du fou qui arrive en
fouillant kétou
donc tourbe et 8 fougue et 3 il va
falloir trouver un autre coup ça peut
être tour ses huit pour ramener une
autre pièce mais ce que les blancs vont
réussir à faire tour f1 et a commencé au
petit à petit maintenant à préparer f4
peut être intéressant ça pour les blancs
à trois avec l'idée tour b8 four b3
c'est vraiment intéressant et b4 qui on
prend pions proches vous remontre l'idea
complète des blancs est maintenant à 4
et du coup on va vouloir a5 a6 a7 et et
ramener le fou en d5 et venir vraiment
gagner sur le pion à
créer bien réalisé par sa chique et
riant
là il a réfléchi très longtemps mais il
a fait une belle série de coups bon je
pense qu'ils connaissent et jusqu'à
fonder cinq faux et fait tache quatre à
cinq mais là la série c3 pour b4 qui on
prend dame 17 et a3
et sur tomber 8 préparation four b3
c'est bien joué
sim qui va jouer je pense qu'il va jouer
tourbe et 8 ans c'est le coup logique
après 1
et on verra après tour des huit fougue
et 3com en continu maxime c'est pas la
crise un attention juste c'est
le statut prince a sacré un statu quo
allèles dame qui al'avantage de sa
chique ya un mais mais comme je le
disais un maxima un pion plus et il n'y
a pas de problème direct dans la
position
max a l'air de vouloir bk tarbes et
quatre
peut-être jouable si on prend qui on
prend lyon prend
pour jouer de manière très directe
alors là c'est vraiment à double
tranchant parce que maintenant si les
blancs réussissent à faire b5 b6 bessède
ça va être gagné pour eux en mettant la
tour en c1 mais peut-être que maxime à
tour b8 ici attaque le pion sur b5 on va
le gagner quand même parce que il ya la
dame et la tour qui attaque contre la
dame seule
si tu es tu vas faire d'armes b3 du coup
pour couvrir l'option est happé par là
je sais pas peut-être eu beau tenter
maintenant kg trois tacles à tour
cavagnac cinq attaques le fou et
cavaliers des 4
c'est complexe mais je crois qu'il veut
tomber 8 ici
il fait une petite main logo bitstream à
l'ancienne lorsqu'il prend la pièce
et joue tour c'est cette
alors tour c'est cette c'est pour faire
passer l'autre tour en b vite
alors nié il ya une énorme question ici
ok ils provoquent ils provoquent
poubelles 6
pour ces huit vous prend à cinq
cavaliers f4
dame
[Musique]
c2c 5
qu'est ce que ça donne ça j'en sais rien
mais clairement il provoque loubet 6
avec tours c'est cette
parce que c'est une double attaque ça
c'est une invitation à un combat de rue
pour ces 7 6 maxime fait tomber 8 au
prochain c'est très bien joué parce que
ça blanc d'oeuf cède sa garde la colonne
de la tour sur la bonne colonne et ça
fait passer le tour ici le seul coup
pour réfuter tour ses sept ses foulées 6
mai après foulée si c'est extrêmement
logique max il va pas faire tour ses
huit direct ça laisserait du fou et 3 il
va faire cavalier f4 la dame va bouger
disons 4 la tour va devoir repartir en
ces
8es le fou apprendre à 5 et qu'est ce
que ça donne ça j'en sais rien
or à tuer système sh-awd s'assurer que
sa position tant vers nulle je veux bien
te croire
mais fou b6 là c'est un vrai coup
fa c'est complexe
et prend des 5 comprend des cinq tours
c'est 4
et 3 10 ans
la tour vient là elle peut venir la dame
peut venir en aide 5 on attaque les
pions je vous rappelle que maxime ne
donne enfin il donne un plus évident
mais il rend un pion il un pion plus à
présent
donc il va s'activer il va rendre un
pion pour s'activer avoir peut-être une
position
avec plus de jeu et pas laisser son
adversaire vie sellal dames et est
contrôlée l'échiquier
pour ce set ça haxhi masque
c'est probablement pas le meilleur coût
objectif
mais vu la situation du tournoi la
réflexion du joueur l'adversaire les
différences de niveaux quand on prend un
peu tout le metagame
on compte tours ce set est un coup très
fort je pense
d'ailleurs il veut pas ça sent qu'il
veut pas le faire sous les 6
faire le pauvre s'affiche à chiquer
riant
sashimis quirion
en sueur
il a déjà tant qu'e du temps l'élu rs 40
minutes certes en 15 20 minutes sur
cette décision
on sent on sent qu'ils tout ce qu'on
vient de se dire là il le sait ça chie
carré ans mais on sent qu'il veut pas
prendre la décision
ah il doit le faire
n'a pas fait baisser si le sexe est fou
b6 le coup
mais il sait que c'est maxime en face et
ça le fait chier de le jouer
parce qu'il veut ça chie
à la maxime qui fait réellement très
très mal je peux vous le dire l'aca doit
fusé dans la tête de sachy
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent
dans la terrasse de sa chique et riant
mais c'est surtout du négatif
il n'a pas obtenu la position qu'il
fallait contre le ministre
sale journée en perspective côté indien
elle et se recroqueville
ça me fait un peu penser aux cloportes
terrible
les cloportes y marcher quand ils ont
peur ils font ils font une boule ce
patient avait déjà vu
qu'est ce que c'est moche les cloportes
terrible
je déteste cet insecte
souffre c'est vraiment dégoûtant comme
truc
non pas d un siècle c'est quoi alors
'cependant c'est que c'est quoi c'est
dégueulasse mais c'est quoi
à jeudi est
ce tracé terrestre rien que le nom ça
dégoûte
c'est terrible
je les mange et quand j'étais enfant art
assez horrible
rim
je raconte moins de solutions mais la
maxi il veut faire trop après s'il va
peut-être se dire je fais foulée 3 quand
même le reste peut être éclairer je
reste sur mon plan tourbe et 8 et
finalement pas si grave ça c'est ce
qu'il espère en fait ça chie je pense
qu'il va partir pour ça
m
il doit hésiter entre foulée 6 et
rentrer dans le jeu de maxime ou faire
une concession à maxime et lui laisser
gagner du temps
à ces terribles all malaise à ça se voit
alors il est pas bien
je l'a perdue la game un sujet encore
perdu
non c'est une fête nous
jeter un oeil du coup c'est terrible
parce qu'en fait j'ai eu le problème
qu'il a c'est qu'ils faisaient un énorme
début de tournoi
et du coup il
n'a fait nulle un moment il fallait pas
non je le sage ou
zéro problème
volot kittin
allez bon il est pas bien
caruana
caruana qui joue pas depuis tout à
l'heure et firoud
j'imagine qu'ils perdent pas cinq
ils le récupèrent hockey
salaire du ce père bien se passer pour
les deux joueurs français
elle est importante aussi pour fille
rousse à laquelle dommage qu'il n'ait
pas battu shirov il aurait battu sur
rafale après la précédente et il ya une
salle là le temps était quasi terminée
déjà
stien le kaki doublé vente qui revient
dans le game dangereux ouais
bien sûr dangereux
double rose s'il avait les noirs
ouais mais c'est vrai que si maxime galy
medumba fin un point non mais on est
très très bien là
mais si prises cinq n'est pas possible
c'est la cata
mais surtout qu'il ya aussi f3 d'en
prendre 5 direct qui est possible
en cuir ou
suivre avec les blancs il a l'air de
faire le taf ça a vraiment l'air d'être
galère
pour nager
halak c'est plus mcphun sa puce maxime
maximale et noir donc c'est normal ça
parti soit plus dur mais la fille rousse
jae peu il peut il peut se remettre
encore un écart
complexe et un + 30 minutes
il se met mal autant trop vite et il le
fait douter maxime son tour ses 7 est
vraiment très malin
c'est cette c'est vraiment très malin
c'est là que tu vois le niveau de maxime
ses couilles en a pas beaucoup qui les
ont un
je vous fais ici sans vie dans le tchat
voilà le truc c'est qu'il est en train
d'utiliser trop de temps pour le jouer
dimanche par un ca marche en fait un
mais mais les noirs ayant un pion plus
iran leur fion il s'active on l'a vu
après le coutour cessé de jouer après
c'est une décision à prendre
jusqu'à maintenant les deux joueurs
français
font le taf qui profitant aussi de
l'absence d'énormément de tops mondiaux
normalement ce tournoi alors il serait
quand même dans les favoris 1 mais à ce
stade là du tournoi on devrait jouer des
joueurs comme rapporte comme guéri comme
mamediarov comme great chioukhs et c'est
vrai que comme nakamura
l'absence d'une multitude de joueurs
créent aussi c'est apparemment un petit
peu
déséquilibré à ce niveau du tournoi
ding wen a man il en manque vraiment
beaucoup un
wesley so
il manque du monde haï manque beaucoup
de monde dont français sont largement
au-dessus de ceux qui sont là ils sont
ils vraiment mieux caruana et aronian
mais à
[Musique]
mais on aurait peut-être moins cette
sensation de domination sans partage si
si les autres favoris s'étaient aussi
déplacés mais après c'est tant pis pour
eux
maxime il à ce qui est véhiculé un
joueur qui était de 1700 ou pas dans le
tournoi
prend pas qu'il ait joué à 2007 maxime
non
moi il a eu six roues mais je voulais
dire dans les reer ou sage nous rappelle
jarre dans les autres les plots qu'il a
pu battre ou quoi
sinon c'est que 26 40 26 50
c'est quand même
pour un point tournoi qualificatif c'est
très faibles sont des joueurs qui sont
au delà de la 100e place aux alentours
de la 100e place mondiale
il a joué tour g1
il a décidé de refuser le pion
sa santé un plus réfléchie c'est plus sa
santé
donc tour g1 ils empêchent cavaliers g3
il prépare tour des f1 et f4
et côté maxime il va y avoir soit ours
et 8 soit tombé à 8 peut-être qu'il va
jouer pour eux c'est 8
août orbite
tranquille ils t'ont j'ai en fait si tu
faisais tour des haies famille avec un
maillage étroit fourchette
donc tour g1 tu veux faire tour f1 et f4
ce que ça donne
maxime je sais pas la petite turbine est
elle davantage la petite sur bin est
telle qu'on pose sur ces huit tours
c'est un tour b 8 le truc c'est un peu
comme le disait cnao dans le chatt ya un
genre de statu quo dans cette position
est un genre de statu quo qui s'installe
parce que les deux joueurs ont du mal à
apprécier de leur côté de l'échiquier
pourquoi il manque autant de monde dans
le tournoi au buy en a qui ont pas voulu
participer d'office on sait pas trop
pourquoi très honnêtement et puis après
avec le confinement il y en a beaucoup
d'autres qui ont décidé de
de se retirer aussi
étrangement position avec tour g1
étaient 40 haulotte est méga analysé
20h53 sur chuck bass à 100 que c'était
la prépa de quelqu'un ici ouais s'abat
sur wii c'est après pas de quelqu'un ça
peut être de quelqu'un extérieur à la
partie mais donc ni maxime nice hachey
mais si c'est l'un des deux s'est plutôt
maxime
il reste 15 courant avant le rajout
autant prendre son temps
sur tours s'est vite alors là je vous
dirais que c'est le coût de leur dit
j'ai pas réfléchi moi je pense à tour
les 8 mai ce que fout mais s'il ya une
qualité a peut-être cavaliers f4 nom qui
tapis si tu bouges la dame on peut taper
des 5 et 6 qui tape ces sept on reprend
du cavale
on va renvoyer des petites pub
qui vont faire du bien
à tout le monde
hama les pubs qui partant ça fait du
bien
ça fait du bien
on souffle ans
donc
maxime qui reprend une réflexion
fin de règne serait terrible
ce temps
riskassur pas et non bien sûr que non
fan ce qui est des plus pour te payer
des surfs c'est ça
enfin passer beaucoup de pub un poids
pour récupérer
ce qu'il doit et maxime qui a joué tour
des huit ans apparemment
par exemple
sinon je crois qu'ils vont ils vont
juste annulé le tournoi qu'on a gagné un
ténébreux minou ya eu trop de trop de
triche des autres équipes et nous en
fait on a été reclassé premier après les
disqualifications d'autres équipes qui
ont triché donc du coup
c'est un peu un peu ce que j'expliquais
quoi souvent c'est un peu là la logique
soit
si on gagne pas parce que des gens
trichent hitchock le truc et du coup ils
nous battent et quand ils se font
attraper le tournant est annulé parce
qu'il ya eu de la triche donc en fait
c'est un peu le serpent qui se mord la
queue
lance amstrong ouais c'est un peu ça
c'est ta pas pu gagner le tour de france
était par classer premier quoi
qu'on verra peut-être qu'on va être payé
par surprise
une tourbe et éviter je pense qu'il va
faire four b3 ici qui était l'idée de
base pour sur b4 avoir pu comprendre que
l'on prend est à 4 le fou protégeant le
pion à 4 dans cette variante
au retour j'ai quatre sur le tour j'ai
quatre c'est pas idiot
c'est une idée qui m'avait échappé
intéressant aussi pour couper
contre la casse des calabrais j'aimais
vraiment bien phu b3 parce qu'en plus ça
trouver 3 que jamais à ces
multifonctions ça t'ouvre la dame sur
des six ça te laisse la place de la case
des cinq vacante éventuellement tu
allais à quatre dans le rêve ça donne
beaucoup de choses en fait
gestion du temps de sa chikhi riant et
assez questionnable ici parce qu'après
tout rejet un tour b 8 était vraiment le
coup mail et c'est bizarre de s'arrêter
pour réfléchir alors à l'heure actuelle
les détours g4 c'est que du coup sur b4
tu peux prendre prendre prendre et que
ta tour elle protège le pion à la fin
il faut b3 permet d'arriver ce sens
qu'elles échangent des dames
ouais m'apprêtais changer tu vas jouer
ça tu vas faire j'ai ici
puis on prend tout reprend le roi reste
quand même assez faible
cinq minutes il va accélérer je pense
quand il en aura 15 mais à mon avis
c'est un peu étrange sur ton g12
reprendre autant de temps après tour b 8
qui était vraiment le coup mail pour les
noirs quoi
parce que là ouais c'est si à tous les
coups même quand on lui joue la ligne la
plus logique qui reprend entre 5 et 10
minutes
dans trois coups il lui reste il y
aurait 6 7 minutes quoi
c'est un petit peu ouais
sainté c'est une variante et une égalité
numérique c'est compliqué à expliquer
pour les débutants et ça jusqu'à un
certain niveau pour vraiment comprendre
c'est dur etc cela
il faut commencer à avoir un certain
niveau pour
pour comprendre ce truc là
psychologique il ya aussi adobe ph le le
côté gauche contre un joueur qui est
plus ou moins retraités des partis l'ont
enfin
c'est c'est vraiment professionnel
contre amateurs à l'heure actuelle en
plus à chicago c'est plus un joueur
d'échecs par correspondance donc c'est
un jeu on réfléchit beaucoup plus et il
a peut-être perdu le côté pas pratiquer
des partis c'est un petit peu
particulier comme comme tournoi je dois
dire parce que c'est vrai qu'on est en
tête du tournoi on est on a dépassé la
moitié du tournoi donc il reste plus que
les meilleurs joueurs c'est un petit peu
comme si en quart de finale de grand
chelem tu joues un amateur quoi un
ex-pro
c'est un petit peu particulier en soi
donc on peut comprendre les difficultés
de sa chique et rien pour le moment il
joue que top coup donc qui mérite d'être
là sains
mais c'est un peu particulier
de 1720 en 2009 à mais c'est un énorme
joueur nyoni bas mai 2009 s'est il ya
douze ans pour ça que je dise un ancien
c'est quand même s'ils jouent un ex pour
un mec qui a été très bon
mais qui a été top 25 30 mondial il ya
une dizaine d'années et qui tape encore
bien mais
voilà il joue un tournant de temps en
temps quoi
la langue
généralement le point faible de ces
joueurs loi ces joueurs là c'est pas les
coûts parce que les coûts ils les ont et
on le voit depuis le début ça chie
thirion là il fait vraiment une
excellente partie le problème c'est le
côté pratique du jeu pratiqué tactique
et c'est ce qui va arriver maintenant
il trouve tout mais y reste 20 minutes
pour quatorze coups et la position va
devenir de plus en plus complexes
après c'est sûr que dans le même ring
geslot l'adversaire de carnas evian est
beaucoup plus difficile
parce que là on a affaire un jeune
joueur je crois qu'il a fait des études
mais il se remet un peu aux échecs
c'est un joueur qui est beaucoup plus
dangereux d'un point de vue pratique et
il vaut mieux jouer un ex-top retraités
qu'un jeune qui a fait des études et qui
se remet aux échecs sérieusement ce
qu'il y en a un qui va être sous classe
et l'autre surclassé il y en a un qui
est pro entre guillemets enfin bon je
pense que vous comprenez
c'est bien il est dangereux
tu préfère jouer sa chique sévillan mais
fashi peux te sortir une partie quasi
parfaite à tout moment parce qu'il a été
avec stop joueurs donc après ça dépend
la partie de fil rouge là ok c'est père
de fou un an pour les blancs pour ali
reza
forcément avant j'ai appris à quel point
on va voir mais en plus ils contrôlent
la case des 8 ce qui est assez important
avec les blancs ça et vite si la colonne
s'ouvre c'est évident que les noirs
puisse installer dessus et ça peut ré
pourrait permettre de rentrer en 17
infi roula et bien après la les pièces
blanches dont il a plus obligations
obligations c'est un grand mot mais il a
plus besoin de gagner que maxime
il vit avec les noirs peu entre
guillemets faire nul aujourd'hui et est
à voir à gagner 2 mains mais avec les
pièces blanches
il y en a un qui al service hot qui en
retour
veut dire qu'un vieux est meilleur en
ouverture final un jeune hier en milieu
de généralement ouais
mais c'est un peu plus complexe que ça
mais pour simplifier oui
ces revirements à ce mass alors je ne
pense pas que tu sont en manque
d'oxygène avec le masque
pense pas
sinon tu serais vraiment pas bien
admettre pendant cinq six heures
d'affilée
manque d'oxygène ça me paraît
après sûr que c'est plus con table de
jouer sans ça
d'un point de vue du confort oui mais
juste chiant ouais c'est ça surtout que
c'est pas obligé de le mettre mais bon
après ça c'est un choix personnel
certains le maître d'autres non pendant
la partie
joue maintenant au roi je suis alors moi
je suit
ça peut ouvrir à l'idée d'un f 5 dame
prend si on prend et il ya plus de g6
parce qu'elle n'est plus que jouer
est ce que les joueurs se lève après
avoir joué en coupe à refaire que non
non c'est juste pour se dégourdir les
jambes
ce que d'un match a été un coup
pas vraiment
j'aurais jamais pensé au cou et
peut-être ressemblent plus à des coûts
de turbines ça pour aller prendre des
pions parce que ça paraît tellement
dangereux mais peut-être ça l'était
au coeur
six mille et une idées ici quand même
une mende coût possible pour les
bleus
lors du
f4f 4 est une possibilité
4 est une possibilité
kiev il veut fou b6 sera pas jouée
f4 sera pas jouer trop dur ça pour ton
prendrait six dames des quatre dames
prend b6 mais ça c'est trop dur
arcade sera pas joué
donc
l'interaction jeunes et hamissi parce
qu'il a un pion de +1
le pion de plus qui peut carry en finale
si on échange les dames qu'on réussit à
faire piéger sept cavaliers f5 on va
être très bien
bref 4 il va pas avoir
je sais pas ce qui peut avoir que vous
aussi tellement dur à jouer
centralise c'est pas mal et sur des
rêves 5 est ce qu'on a quelque chose de
direct et fort
on peut même temps pau parce que du coup
pris ce prise ce changement de structure
est cool pour les blancs parce que vous
voyez ces cinq pions sont vraiment
bloqué par les trois pions blancs
en fait à vrai dire cette structure-là
bon là on va peut-être pas prendre ce
que le cavaliere revient mais en fait
l'option de quatre blocs bien le pion à
des six en quelque sorte
d'âme 4 rassemblerait une idée le seul
inconvénient c'est que ça
[Musique]
n'attaque plus le pion des six
me 4 pas comment maxime peut progresser
je vois pas comment les blancs progresse
vraiment non plus
7 pour se décaler
oui
dur très dur à jouer comme position
on dira juste après termine 4ème jour
évidemment 7
pensez f4 possible et il peut trouver un
f4 comprend foulée six tours tomber six
dames des quatre
cette idée est complexe parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de variantes il réussit les a4
intermédiaire il ya beaucoup de choses
possibles
m
richard krishnan
son immense problème ici c'est sa
gestion du temps en fait là l'échiquier
c'est parfait mais 15 minutes
en réalité ça me fait un peu écho à ce
que disait fabi hier
en parlant des parties longues et de ce
qui se passait à son niveau donc c'est
un niveau est plus proche de celui que
de ça chez qui rien que ça shikari en
eux les deux maxime exe souvent en fait
si tu réfléchis longtemps pour jouer des
parties longues et joué quelques bons
coups mais en gros ça se décide quand
même surtout on zappe note un manque de
temps un petit peu comme dans un blitz
et là j'ai peur pour sa fille quirion
que ce soit le scénario de la partie
c'est difficile
il reste 6 minutes 30 parcours puisqu'il
a 30 secondes de rajouts parcours et
c'est pas énorme
surtout que la position peut
largement se compliquer et s'ouvrir
x
va jouer tour gf
alors tour j'ai fait intéressant donc il
veut f4 donc clairement il a pas trouvé
l'idée de f4 on prend et publicis mais
j'avais dit que c'était très dur juste
d'y penser
il veut f4 à présent donc ya la méthode
dure et gala méthode douce alors la
méthode douce la méthode dure ces
cavaliers f4 fou prend un pion prend et
là-dessus l'idée des blancs peut être
d'envoyer h simcoe
et d'aller jouer sur le rock
c'est une première une première chose
possible
ah mais ça paraît dangereux la deuxième
chose c'est de profiter de la tour qui
est vraiment parti pour se replacer en f
5 et fermer la colonne mais là peut-être
il veut ton j'ai un cavalier f5 et h5
très complet une nouvelle fois cavalier
prend dame prend
il faudra juger du danger de l'attak des
blancs sur la colonne tâche très
complexe très complexe c'est une autre
méthode on va essayer un petit peu de
regarder les coûts candidat parce que là
il ya vraiment beaucoup d'options donc
car elle et j'ai trois cavaliers f4
alors après ce qu'on a des méthodes des
4 c b à b à 4 essayé de combiner mais le
truc c'est qu'il réussit vraiment bien
bloquer les colonnes avec les blancs
maxime va jouer la maxime qu'il est en
train de faire c'est vraiment très fort
parce qu'il est en train de réfléchir
sur le temps de sachy pour le mettre
sous pression c'est insupportable il
part pour cavaler g3 c'est vraiment très
très bien joué de la part de maxime
la maxime veut lui mettre la tête sous
l'eau en fait y prend un risque maximal
or il prend pas un risque au niveau des
coûts qu'ils jouent mais il prend un
risque au niveau de la vitesse de jeu et
ça pour moi c'est très bien joué parce
que maxime il va se tromper une fois sur
dix en jouant vite parce que c'est un
mario absolue et pour encore s'en sortir
mais en revanche qui met énormément de
fautes dans le règne de sachy ça ça
c'est vraiment c'est comme ça qu'il
avait fait craquer chiant que c'est
comme ça qu'il a fait craquer tabataba
et il fait souvent craqué les joueurs de
ce règne comme ça et tour g1 a donc
proposition de drouot et maxime qui
revient cavale et h5
ok il revient une fois mais peut-être
pas d'eux
peut-être pas d'eux les amis
lama qui propose la drau entre
guillemets
mais c'est pas dit que sur tours f1 -il
refasse cavale et g3
c'est à dire sur touré fin changé d'avis
et faire suer sachy là si j'étais sa
chique irions honnêtement c'est tour
eiffe un tempo en fait et je donne la
responsabilité de la décision aux
requins
parce que si tu prend 5,6 vrai c'est
bien joué aussi de sachy tu peux pas te
permettre avec aussi peu de temps de
chercher un autre coup de décider après
prendre la droit et te [ __ ] mal autant
aller la maxime va réfléchir
il connaît les intentions maintenant de
sachy et là ça va être la maxime de
décider s'ils partent pour le cavalier
g3 damas trois vallées maintenant ils
enlèvent le badge et il va réfléchir
c'est extrêmement bien joué de la part
de maxime il a rajouté de la pression
psychologique mais bien éviter aussi de
la part de sa fille qui a pas trop
tergiverser qui acceptent de prendre là
nul mais il se met en position de
dominer un forcément puisqu'il donne la
responsabilité du choix à maxime est ce
que tu veux jouer le gain ou non et là
bon là ça va être un jugement de maxime
suivant les risques suivants ce qu'ils
pensent
après le petit défaut de ce qu'il a fait
comme ça je dis rien quand même bien
réagi c'est que ça rapprochait de deux
coups ça chie quirion du du 40e et du
rajout de temps
hamon
répéter ici va tenter de jouer la gagne
vous propose d un cavalier j'ai trois
tours h1 d'alger damage froid ça peut
être joué par maxime
mais c'est très gentil très dangereux
qui a figé trois cavaliers f5
et g3 tour g1 qui a valu à 5 y avait 2 h
sinko 1 ça peut être double tranchant
l'impression qui va jouer en effet un
petit mouvement demain
il repart et comme dit robinson il est
tellement fort avec les blancs depuis
début juin qu'il peut aussi vouloir
rassurer possible aussi
comme dirait villa d'isle peut vouloir
s'assurer
5 maxime sait que c'est dante annuler
toujours il va prendre la drau
on va voir là c'est maxime qui décide
à
ouais
cavaliers h5 ça donnerait tour f1
d'euros 1
et maxime qui va demander la drau
un pré carré dhs et maxime qui peut déjà
prendre rois pré carré dh 5
maxime a arrêté la pendule il va
chercher un arbitre évidemment c'est
très difficile à arbitrer les échecs
donc les arbitres ne sont sont
systématiquement loin des partis c'est
quand même un jeu comme vous pouvez le
voir il ya souvent beaucoup de
deux problèmes d'arbitrage donc les
arbitres sont vraiment très très très
occupé
et donc il a dû arrêter la pendule aller
chercher lui-même larbitre ses complexes
1 il ne joue que table 2
voilà et ouais ça chie quirion qui fait
un petit à un petit geste de la main il
ne conteste pas la drau est signé et
maxime voilà qui prend le demi point
bien joué de la part de maxime il
pouvait probablement pas faire plus
c'est une belle partie
sa chique yankee à qui a réussi à jouer
top abeilles se lave les mains c'est
vrai que
il le fallait et il propose déjà la
maxima n'en maxine langer mongel
est oui maxime qui ne va pas se faire
piéger par le gel de sa chique ayant
bien joué bien vu de la part de maxime
hilal al fadl bien évidemment
maxime chère viande tournoi petite droit
avec les noirs et donc demain on
reviendra bosser avec les blancs
donc on va aller voir maintenant la
partie d'alireza
joue table 1
le leader du tournoi co-leader avec
maxime mais leader au départage donc
contre nager on peut repasser la partie
rapidement
c'était une belle partie de maxime
maintenant c'est demain que ça va être
primordial 1
il lui reste à maxime il reste combien
il reste 1 en 4 parties restent blancs
de noirs
et normalement il faut faire trois sur
quatre pour gagner deux ennemis peut
suffire
suivante qui bat suivant les résultats
des autres
gerbe sont quand même belle ils se
dépouillent dangereux strahl safe
pleutre je prends avec nos régates avec
les blancs
ah bah oui mais c'est ce qu'il faut
faire en réalité
il y a d'où il a trois blanc un noir
aussi exactement des virils charrs
il ya un rennes joue il a trois blancs
encore
on
verra contre qui il joue un
on va voir comment commencer à contient
ou une petite pub à la fin de la partie
la pub qui a été oublié un
énorme erreur du streamer français
qui auraient pu ne pas pub et ça aurait
été terrible
ça aurait été bhl
oui le petit part
autour d eux
c'était une petrov
il alla garde-fous
la paire de faro
puis si on est noir
man
sur le fil
ouais en fait ce fonds ces sept à manger
ici si on n'arrive pas à les déconnecter
jeudi connaît on ira voir un peu on
passera à voir
c'est dommage si perd encore aujourd'hui
puisque d'un baudet but un magnifique
début de tournoi il peut se retrouver
malon perdant contre deux joueurs à
moins de 26
je crois alireza il a joué fouache 4
prépare quoi en réalité
en fait je vois que les blancs sont
mieux mais j'essaye de comprendre ce
qu'ils préparent
après peux jouer tranquille en fait il à
la paire de fou il a ce pion aux cinq
qui est très fort et si réussi à faire
j'ai quatre fous g3 décaler la dame et
f4 f5 il a gagné mais ça c'est dur
mais je pense qu'ils préparent ans et
prépare juste fou j'ai 3 des cas la dame
f4 et peut-être flou h2 g4 f5 plus tard
attendez je vais me préparer un petit
même
je vais me faire un p'tit même les gars
pendant que ça joue
je suis très heureux
attendait
comment faire
alors qu'on nous ont même préféré
j'arrive pas à le faire terrible
je vais faire un petit même
je sais pas s'il est drôle ou pas
je sais pas s'il est drôle ou pas j'ai
pas le faire
du coup il revoit à schwyz n'y a plus
personne à la table
elle ordonne terminée
non et je les maîtres ont même préféré
avec le petit jeu de squid game
lemaitre très heureux maxime avec les
blancs et en sueur avec les noirs
ouais tu gagnes tout en un avec les
blancs et il fait tout en tuant vos
droits avec les noirs
si je peux le faire je vais jouer je
vais le mettre
je vais le mettre
apparemment il ya foule et 5 d'après
leur dit qu'ils gagnent le pion des 4es
la partie en force
je fais mon petit truc
à
j'aurai mon petit tweet au mans c'est
fait et donc alors dit qu'il faut b5 à
essayer de comprendre pourquoi il veut
france et 6 puis on prend ici dakar ça
c'est simple à comprendre et aimer sur
décédera retour des si c'est ça non et
puis on prend quand même manqué
ouais tu menaces tour des six aussi
tour 6 qui devrait partir
ok c'est pas un gain direct mais c'est
juste que tu commences à organiser
toutes les pièces comme tu le souhaites
pas de lien direct mais
la dame se retrouve aussi à court de
cases
la tour va rentrer en dix-sept wayne en
fait ça rentre de partout
jordan f5 je pense ça va bien illustré
dame prend angers 4 pour regagner le
contrôle de 17
fou quelque part tu as déjà trop de cast
avec 4 qui arrive mona seif cinq tours
17 à tous qu'ils rentrent
b5 très fort mais il le rate
il a joué f3
pleutre ados et que la raddho
mais elle croit c'est aussi un très bon
coup en fait ils préparent fief 2
bien vidéo demain sur la partition là
parce que lors de coups change tout et
je comprends pas vraiment pourquoi oh
c'est pas sûr qu'on analyse leurs deux
coureurs c'est loin d'être dit
on va voir ses vian à craquer ça peut
être important on va les jeux tarn avec
haruna qui prend des risques
c'est pas dit qu'il ait craqué la
position est complexe fabiano qui
réussit pas à exercer de pression clean
sur ses adversaires
car voix c'est violent volent kittin
aronian
caillé tout c'est bien juste la position
est tendu un
juge juste pour voir parce qu'on disait
qu'il était dans le dur
non pas du tout la position est tendue
ce pass est enfin il se passait il se
passe des choses mais il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de problème et hand slimana
peut être intéressant pour maxime
gentz imany les gagnants contre sinndar
off ça c'est cool pour le départage
ok
il fait pour tout le temps bouger son
oreille
doit bouger les muses de sa tête sans
arrêt c'est impressionnant
la position a l'air tellement dur f3c
bien joué
lajoux et b6
un bébé si ça va renforcer le flou b5 en
réalité
n'a pas des 3 pour les noirs 1 il a joué
à six il empêche le foot b5
détroit
c'était peut-être un coup je pense à
première vue que le pion serait très
faible
il le sera mais c'était peut-être un
essai
parce que les blancs les mages ont la
majorité et surtout le fou ces deux ils
se retrouvent complètement coupé du jeu
sûrement les blancs vous faire quelque
chose comme fief de taper le pion b si
c'était de faire un b3 pour empêcher ces
quatre et par la suite ils vont essayer
de s'organiser pour faire l'avant
l'avancé allèles
allait droit et le pion détroit est mal
donc à 6,6 se prémunit des fous b5
il veut aussi peut-être dans son règne
parfois des 3b 5 c 4 1 ce cas devrait
dire c4 était jamais possible à cause de
la dame qui contrôle le pion
je pense aux idées sur france 2 c'est
que ça l'hiver la case des huit pour la
tour
du coup je sais pas comment il doit
continuer à les résa ça se sent qu'il
est bien
mais c'est pas aussi facile que ça de
concrétiser
y avoir un nouvel équipier nico demain
ce qui à mon avis serait une bonne
nouvelle pour maxime parce que si belle
si penka avec les blancs c'est quasi
calif
enfin il restera encore trois parties
mais
tu fais un pas énorme vers la qualif et
s'il fait nul il est encore très bien
dans la course ce que patrice ipn cas en
fait c'est une gagne avec les blonds ce
que tu devais faire tu élimines d'un de
tes adversaires directs et plus
dangereux qui aura un bon départagera en
fait je fais tellement de choses
un aspect un café rue zhao si demain
c'est les résas et seul en tête andreï
risque d'être flotteurs montant
ouais alors après il ya aussi les
couleurs les machins dur à dire ça
devient de plus en plus difficile à
calculer parce qu'il faut connaître
l'historique du tournoi
il a joué fouet veut donc mayer va jouer
autour des 8
avec un des deux doubles et alireza
ouais il va pas mais en fait y en a
aucun des deux qui peut vraiment doublé
quoi
après peuvent doubler les noirs
ouais bon c'est compliqué c'est
difficile à dire
ça dépend de beaucoup trop de facteurs à
présent
sans son gardien sarine et sachions ce
qui est embêtant avec les indiens qui
sont enfin là avec sa sarine et sa
chique erian s'ils sont tous les deux à
cinq c'est qu'en fait si je joue entre
eux ils peuvent mettre des points en
jouant entre plots quoi
du coup ça peut être un peu embêtant
c'est eux c'est un peu la multitude des
plots qui peut être un danger pour la
qualif en fait s'il y avait moins de plo
caruana aussi très important
très important la partie de fabiano
c'est bien s'ils gagnent avec les noirs
ça pourrait être un joueur embêtant
aussi
viennent cas c'est pas dit qu'ils
gagnent encore d'ailleurs
c'est pas terminé
ras
c'est vraiment terminé par les parties
deviennent plus plus tendue
peut-être avoir ariane tahri tahri à 5
sur 7 c'est exceptionnel
et du coup il ya beaucoup de joueurs à 5
sur 7 c'est un peu ça le danger c'est
qu'ils jouent entre eux et ils peuvent
gagner des parties quoi
pour ça que pour ses importants pour
fuir ou de se mettre à cinq et demi
le mal qu'ils peuvent faire et encore ça
reste à voir c'est de s'entendre pour
que l'on porte le mieux placé
il peut faire beaucoup de choses
c'est bien il ya 4 je crois
hong
key
à
du coup
coût du coup du coup je voulais regarder
classement
également spa 2007 changer le classement
elo là je me disais en faites pas ce que
je cherchais un est le classement elo
maxime qui reste top 10 bon de toute
façon ça ca
c'est assez anecdotique je vais regarder
par rapport aux appariement
et c'est bien qu'il ya quatre donc il
remontera à cinq points seulement s'ils
gagnent mais bon il va pas gagner
qu'est ce qui est plus entre battre en
1750 avec les blancs ou 1 2650 avec les
noirs ça dépend des joueurs mais pour
maxime de plus facile de battre à 27,50
avec les blancs
les parties d'un pas décidé mais il est
bien dans la partie
d'un gars
qui peuvent tout échanger sur tour des
huit
mois il va gagner le pion 1
bat
attendait ici sans fait ce à quoi
j'étais en train de penser et iannitto
dernier tour quatre
tours des huit ça défend le pion de
manière tactique
ouais donc tour des huit ça défend
en quelque sorte d'être prendre prendre
tous ces quatre
fait on est tellement bien de toute
façon à long terme
ouachin même peut-être pour mener assez
fou prend
je vais avoir du t3 et du tarn 3 et du
f4 et du filet 4 et du coup j'ai 2
je crois qu'il avait tourné huit suis
pas sûr ouais c'est ce qu'il a fait
c'était le coup logique hein
c'était le coup logique
bien ouais
mal
reste à flot une manne qui gagne ça fait
plaisir et c'est bien pour le départage
ça
évidemment c'est très bien pour le
départage
fait là encore c'est une position avec
avantage pour les blancs mais ya pas de
variantes concrètes il ya beaucoup de
coups différents jouable l'idée c'est
vraiment d'essayer de jouer sur ce 4
contre 3 fr une expansion allait droit
d'aller voir plusieurs manières d'y
arriver les noirs veulent un peu bloqué
le jeu avec le pion décès et s'active et
peut-être un jour avec le cheval
et non les devants les blancs
malheureusement ne gagne pas le pion des
à cause du dame b 6 à la fin qui vient
effectuer le clouage on peut pas
protéger parce que là le fou et bloque
les deux coups de protection de la tour
jolie géométrie
la partie devrait se décider il reste 17
quoi jouer en un peu moins d'une heure
la partie devrait se décider maintenant
parce que ça fait beaucoup de coups et
si les blancs réussissent à mettre la
marche avant ils vont gagner
si les noirs a réussi sacré du contre je
allèles dames et empêcher ce plan ça
donnera une nulle donc logiquement on
devrait en savoir beaucoup plus ça dans
la demi-heure et leur avenir
l'atelier les bonnes et hyper mal le ton
a foiré pour lui totalement ouais
ça m'étonne pas vraiment
why la taupe
turbines du fou h4 c'est pas mal pas
déjà fou h45 ci revient avec la tour en
huit on revient à la position dans
laquelle on était précédemment
donc non et puis en plus ça lui donne du
tour dès cette fin en soi il revient
dans la position qu'il avait deux coups
avant soit il peut même s'améliorer
peut-être avec tours 17
ouais les bonnes si déjà si feignies je
pense que c'est quasi fini pour la gagne
il aura un microscopique shot mais c'est
quasi fini en revanche s'il perd il et
on ne le reverra plus
et harry qui est pas mal c'est vraiment
incroyable ça et you may où il a un demi
point de retard maintenant
il va pas gagné donc ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle
tabatabai je regarde un peu les anciens
adversaires de maxime ou d'alireza
et harry vous dites il est pas mal
contre zoug et rohff
ça pourrait être extraordinaire que
taris qualifier bon nous on n'est pas
pour mais ce serait quand même drôle
d'avoir un plot candidats
après le mieux c'est qu'il ait pas trop
de joueurs qui montent honnêtement ce
qui nous arrange le plus pour ses
joueurs qui sont à égalité de points
avec maxime enfin qui sont à quatre là
qui sont derrière le petit groupe c'est
qu'il y en ait pas qui remontent pour
que maxime en gagnant ils réussissent à
prendre un point complet d'avant sur eux
pour qu'ils puissent vraiment plus
revenir
là encore de bonnes chances pour la
qualif ouais
hachez les appariements
reims système suisse
france 4 si toi mais le truc c'est que
si vous regardez le scénario de la
partie
flash 4 3 h suite f 3 6 6 vient de faire
flouer f2 tour des huit donc s'il fait
foi h4
soual et noir reviennent à 8 et on
revient à la même position qu'on avait
précédemment sur les joues tour 17 qui
est peut-être une amélioration par un
peut-être ça marche pas du tout pour la
vous dites qu'il ya eu 6 effectivement
ça joue sur le clouage et
et ça va gagner mais ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que revenir en hqe avec le
fou ça fait pas trop sens
tu vas pas tant t as regardé fois h4 et
à calculer s'il peut améliorer le la
position de sa tour quand tu viens de
faire flouer f2
g4 c'est un coup intéressant pour
préparer dame g3 f4 f5 qui peut être
très fort parce que ça couperet la
connexion du fou et de l'adam
g4 pour moi c'est clairement un coup et
on peut se permettre d' affaiblir le roi
parce qu'on a le x f1 qui peut revenir
devant
h4 envisageable comme le plan c d'un
espion f5 c'est plus logique de faire
j'ai quatre
ça paraît logique
c'est pour ça de jouer j'ai kapoor
d'alger 3 battu cours et f4 f5 après
et foi h4 la première ligne de leur dis
j'y crois pas du tout je vois pas dans
quel monde tu reviens
jusqu'à ce que tu veux c'est prendre et
4,15
il recommande de jouer a cédé je
comprend pas la différence en fait
ça c'est la variable alors dit je
comprends pas la diff
en fait moi j'aime bien garder les pions
je préfère regarder les pions parce que
du coup ci prend prend il a un problème
avec lui
ou s'il veut pousser
dans les deux cas elle un problème avec
ses 5
je préfère avoir ses deux pions en vie
on prend pas le ouf parce qu'il est
protégé
ouais
[Musique]
je sais pas comment il réagit à g4 à
vrai dire
la turbine est d'un f5 et un coup c'est
vrai très thématiques
il n'y a pas tord france est 2e à cause
de pions prend probablement
les bandes armées quatre noms mais bon
ça c'est n'importe quoi
non j'ai quatre f5 j'y crois pas une
seconde
sur b3 un ânon la m5 qui aurait tout
repenser de direct parce que le pion
peut pas bouger
pour ce faire
ils attaquent le fou
est-ce qu'il a regardé pendant si
longtemps j'imagine que c'est des 3a nom
des trois il faut penser 5 pardon
bref 5 du coup il veut quoi
est ce que maintenant il peut faire
pions trempions prend fut un cavalier
prend en dames b6 tordères
comme une question
peut-être ça marche maman
à vrai dire dame prend b2 on a tout
reprend des huit
ici prend des quatre premiers on prend
la dame mon défaut
donc ça semble passé
les pendant si longtemps j'imagine
détroit et la c5 comme il n'a pas pris
en d4 avant
pour huit ans à ses pions de plus
peut-être pas vraiment de bons coups
pourra d'ailleurs
je peux te montrer la variante russe
on avance et ff5 puis on prend pions
prend fou prend
cavaliers prendre pour prendre un bain
et 6 tout à l'heure le fouetter en c2
bloquer les protections et maintenant
qu'il n'y ait plus on peut faire trop d
1 et surtout c'est à dire la tour d2
conserve la tour on va jouer roy ashburn
un pion plus
il a joué foubert alors attendez
si on joue ça comme ça il peut prendre à
2 à la fin
ok
donc il veut gagner un temps là dessus
bien joué faut bien
plus de six minutes il va falloir
accélérer
[Musique]
pour tout le temps boucher ses oreilles
en fait
soit c'est parce qu'il a des tics
nerveux soit il ya quelque chose
et à 3 3 c'est un coup mais ça laisse le
temps aux blancs de faire quelque chose
au noir de faire quelque chose parc
pardon là peut-être un coup comme
cavalier à 5 maintenant pour essayer de
profiter de la case b3 et détours pas
très bien placé
et particuliers ces mouvements d'oreille
attention c'est vraiment très étrange
ray
heureusement qu'on a la came pour voir
ça ouais
pourquoi la pub à on est sur une chaise
comme un pub de partout hein
oui
la base
je vais prendre un petit truc à manger
au passage arrive avant le avant le gros
de saïx note je mange un tout petit truc
j'arrive profite de la pub
bon ça va j'ai rien rater
j'ai mangé une pomme
tellement bon les pommes
à jouer quoi du coup pas vu le coup
il a pris des 4
monkey peut-être céder
à 3 mais quand même cavalier à 5 et 10
la turbine
4 kébé 3ème et là ça sent qu'il va y
avoir un problème
lorsqu'un débiteur conduite et tourouvre
caire
donc c'est décédé à a3
mais en fait il ya peut-être un problème
parce qu'il ya plus des trois maintenant
lorsque le fou et en c2 le pion protéger
le fou mais maintenant il ya tout
reprend br
c'est ça la diff
et c'est une grosse différé alité
winona 4,83 plus logique quand même
plus solide
ça va être difficile pour nayyar là
chez moi
m
des gens identifiés ou et l'appartement
sais rien
bah non mais bon quand tu que je sache
que l'appartement 106
ya les numéros sur les portes mais
j'imagine qu'il faut aller à un autre
étage quoi
donc je comprend des 4 way à 3 et en
fait on peut plus défendre le pion
c'est ça le problème pour nayyar
il
il a pris du cheval
ouais faut prendre si on prend et
a3 et l'idée c'est qu'il y aura pas de
dames b6 le fousseret a attaqué il ya
plus des traces a assez bien joué
c'est prend et a3 est en fait tu peut
plus sauver le pion
ah les geeks et à tripoli des doigts ça
dans le chat avait fait gaffe ont
attendu une semaine ludwig
ouais
c'était avec vlad qui est positif pour
être sûr de pas l'avoir fabriquée ph
dans le chat ou quoi mais je crois que
tu dois attendre encore six
prière on était quoi
on était mardi
devrait tu dois attendre le 9 pour être
sûr
pour être vraiment sûr sûr
sur toi tu es dan terrible
bateau - t'as pas attendre tu le sais
j'en prends est là dessus à trois et
c'est sûr tu gagnes le pion en fait
après gagné non non c'était pareil en
fait dans tous les cas il va perdre le
pion il peut pas faire d'un v6 qui a le
four b3 en l'air il peut pas faire des 3
bon là samax aeio affirme john jouer il
va jouer à trois
ou à quatre mais il peut pas faire des 3
pascal foubert en l'air du coup vous
qu'après un simple coup comme à troyes
il est dans la sauce en vrai
ouais c'est jouer en fait c'était tout
l'idée d'alireza quand il a fait un tour
c'est
s'était déplacé le fou pour prendre
prendre prendre et qui est pas de
détroit et plus les défenses à base de
detroit
mais il faudra 3 et le pion et perdu en
réalité
il n'y a pas de défense pour ce pion
tour est fait huit ans reprend des
quatre
dames des six tours d1
et on va décaler le roi et ce sera pion
de plus
ça devrait pouvoir aller jusqu'à la
victoire ça vraiment dommage qu'il ait
pas battu scheer enfin ali reza avant
avant-hier
parce qu'il aurait un point complet d'
avance sur ses poursuivants et il aurait
déjà tué le tournoi
même si là il va prendre une sacrée
option un
fait nul la prochaine noir il a de
nouveau les blancs y gagner c'est
terminé
on souvent été un bon coup je sais par
la position était vraiment difficile
car avec souffre chaque partie et il a
régressé caruana
suire avons encore s'en sortir ça ce
serait une excellente nouvelle pour
maxime
ou alors c'est loin d'être fait ou
je ne sais pas s'il va s'en sortir ou
pas là la position est extrêmement
complexe vous regardez tête à
l'ordinateur mais honnêtement quand tu
es en partie latence est rien beaucoup
de choses peuvent encore arriver mais
caruana qui gagne pas ça ce serait aussi
une aubaine
et surtout qui va peut-être même perdre
il est vraiment mal avec son roi au
centre
il va y avoir un gros trail t-notes mais
caruana s'il perd aujourd'hui lui aussi
les complètement éliminé un
match nul il resterait un demi point
derrière maxime et la défaite il se
retrouve à un point derrière avec un
départage qui va être pour av il pourra
pas remonter normalement fabiano
donc on pourrait aujourd'hui
perdre les bonnes et fabiano caruana de
la course aux candidats
ça peut ça serait une excellente une
excellente nouvelle si ça pouvait se
combiner avec une nulle discipline cas
qui rate shirov
je dit que demande le peuple
il resterait qui pour maxi mon
adversaire by resterait 2 bat déjà
n'importe quel plots parce qu'il en a
beaucoup donc l'alarmé des plots je
dirais qu'ils seraient un adversaire une
armée qui représenterait un adversaire
est peut-être un duo et scipione cas du
boeuf qui sera notre adversaire
l'armée des qui peut être dangereuse 1
ouais
ça va même s'il fait nul avec les blancs
et une belle op
ça ils sont tellement nuls en dix ans
les plots mais c'est un peu comme les
zombies il y aurait tellement que dans
le tas il peut y en avoir un qui te bats
c'est exactement ça
peut rencontrer qu'imax demain
va falloir attendre les résultats
voir tard il peut y avoir du monde
encore un
navarra
risque c'est bien la star one a gagné
par patrick izard a complètement je
pense que ces viandes et qui joue un mec
américain il dit je vais perdre exprès
complètement
à laleu même pour nager c'est qu'il faut
savoir comment bien donner le pion pour
avoir des chances de faire nul dans la
finale mais en réalité la finale a l'air
tellement mauvaise
pour karen en quelques coups ce qui
serait une bonne opération
caruana ça à faire nul il va pas la
perdre
seillant qui a pas réussi à le battre on
les donne c'est terminé cavaliers f5 il
va perdre g7 et g5
1 et non les vans et c'est terminé
il va reculer dans la hiérarchie
mondiale
mondiale le joueur arménien
tienne cas on va voir si réussi à
terminer shirov
ok
une ag qui sut
moment-là nul de c'est bien c'est bon
pour nous un
c'est pas un mauvais résultat
fabiano il reste il reste à distance
mais en revanche est ce que fabiano peu
flotté montant demain sur maxime ou sur
fear où il faut que je regarde ça il
faut que je checke parce que là nul
allait elle est assurée de ce côté là
est ce qu'il ya du flotteur 27
ah oui mais attends maxima et ménagers
va perdre sa chique irions
ok ça dépend ces taureaux
à maxime va jouer soit scheer oif
soit ici viennent qu'au probablement au
blanc sisi pikogan normalement il va
jouer scipione qu à moins que il n'y a
qu'à new here est non il ya encore des
du monde qui n'a pas qui n'a pas fini
c'est dur à dire
ce qui a dû tard aussi dans leur haine
jeu s'ils gagnent c'est un peu bizarre
là parce qu'il ya beaucoup de jeux de
couleurs
fondues les blancs les noirs on sait pas
exactement qui va monter
paris avec les blancs serait le rêve des
paris qui va être égalité 1
harry maxime au blanc ça ce serait idéal
jouer tari au blanc ce serait idéal
évitez fabi maxime est en réalité il
peut éviter fabi jusqu'à la fin du
tournoi c'est ça qui est le plus
incroyable
on va voir
et les bombes à lacets tour g8 dont g7
au g5 1
terminée pour les bonnes
terrible des images terribles
il a joué fois de du coup
et il peut prendre le purin déjà
revenu de cajon à jerez est allé à l'onu
la position de famille
et il est pris le pouls tôt et dames b6
d'un tiers à tour des 1 c'est le seul
coup sinon perdre et la tour
et tours 8
donc nayer qui va tenter une défense
maintenant
j'imagine rouages de ici permet de se dé
cloud et
prises des 4 et après prise des cas de
prise des caprices des caprices des
quatre les pardons et proust et 4 est
prise aux 5 les noirs ont un problème
c'est le match du couloir alors il
pourrait tenter un epci ce pour se
couvrir mais là le truc c'est juste
qu'on prend prend et tours 17 on
n'aurait pas le temps
3 2 qui va être joué c'est le coup le
plus logique
probablement pas les premières lignes
mais les plus logiques prises des
castings qui va prendre de la dame ça
lui permet de libérer le pion f
il voyait que les problèmes de temps
sont quasi inexistants pour ali reza
maintenant il a trois minutes met dans
une position
très propre très simple à jouer très
saine avec un pion plus sans activité
pour l'adversaire alors il prend son
temps évidemment
ça me prendrait quatre en plus ça
protège le pion b200 on en a souvent
parlé mais ça libère
ça libère f ça fait tout ce coup
ali reza qui devrait prendre se
reprendre seul la tête entre guillemets
ce qui lie l'ue était seul seul leader
et il va reprendre possession de son
bien
carole lindros signé ça c'est bien car
ouanna qui reste un peu embués
attention il faudra se méfier de fabiano
ils jouent mal fabiano il est pas dans
le tournoi mais il n'est qu'à un demi
point derrière maxime
ça peut faire penser à la squadra
azzurra en coupe du monde ça joue pas
très bien au groupe mais ça clutch à la
fin il faudra se méfier il suffit qu'il
engage une avec les noirs après il joue
maximo blanc il regagne dans une major
de folie et les regrets pour nous donc
il faudra s'en méfier un temps qui n'est
pas distant fabiano
ils étaient quand même numéro deux
mondial pendant des années
même en très très petite forme
il est là donc y laissa échanges toutes
les pièces
voyez au niveau de la pendule un ça va
complètement
et g 5 donc j'ai cinq un joli coup donc
l'idée c'est de d'enlever le mag du
couloir et d'attaquer le pion aux 5 et
maintenant il doit y avoir tour 17 pour
taper le pion b
et a6 sera en ligne de mire
ça doit gagner
on suit le travail oui je sais on a fait
une vidéo dessus toujours se méfier des
des grands joueurs comme ça en méforme
tant qu'il reste à flot tu sais pas ce
qui se passe à un moment donné il ya une
partie qui tourne bien ils reprennent
confiance et ils marchent sur l'eau
imagine que firova prendre le
le pion des sept
voiles assez joué ça
sur quoi
il va hésiter avec b5 peut-être
il va hésiter entre temps prend 2,5 pour
prouver cette a5
et b5 tour à 7h35 tôt reprend 1,6
avec b5 justement
il s'accroche aux branches
bref à bien à tout moment on peut
claquer des victoires il peut ses salles
dans gmail étals de fabrice qui prend
les risques avec les noirs
et il est tout à fait capable d'en
claquer une tour des six
or prendre tout reprend 1,6
tour euh ça peut arriver ce genre de
choses
attention hein pas faire rage il y aura
poussé quatre attention cloche sur la
première ne sera sûrement food et 3
peu a réussi à voir du tout rage 6,3 7,1
jours
et surtout rien à [ __ ] en bessin quoi
exact est encore pire
pendant donc c'est vraiment fini
complètement ratée faut prendre les cinq
ans
pas de couvrir cette ça on l'a vu en moi
je voulais prendre huit mais oui sur toi
on a carrément faut prendre les 5
atout qui gagne
plutôt cool à tour à 8 on n'a même pas
envie de regarder c'est trop passifs
lyon 2 - passivité ça tient jamais
il reste quoi il reste tour cinq tours à
6 pouces et quatre
ans et 4 des français 4 ok c'est seule
chance
c'est ça sa chance de jouer cette finale
il peut y avoir des règnes de draw là
dedans
ok c'est clairement le seul coup tout
réussi sept as finale de fou ça va
quasiment toujours perdre
et là il doit tenter fous ces quatre en
fait
ces quatre fous prends tu dois plus ou
moins pions temps
et tour
b6 peut-être
ok c'est ce qui joue en ailleurs c'est
la seule chance
ont prises et là il faut faire un bon
coup
vous ces quatre fois champion en pour
ces six je pense ça là elle gagne pas
non
ça je pense que ça gagne pas
y'a pas longtemps
sur les postes 2 à brooke là sur
facebook il y avait une finale à trois
contre trois comme ça avec un pion de
côté
et c'est pas sûr que le pion g5 se soit
pas une bonne nouvelle pour les noirs en
fait
ça ça doit être nul
il est l'arbitré lui faire quelque chose
on est juste en train de réfléchir
affirme scénario il n'aime pas quand les
gens viennent faire du bruit à côté
rage est raté
pas
j'ai pas vu
juste en train de calculer moi j'ai les
yeux fermés en train de calculer la
finale
bon après le fait que les joueurs
veulent pas être filmés et c'est moi
j'veux pas ça très bien honnêtement
parce que bah ils gagnent des millions
par an et au bout d'un moment
bah ça fait partie du métier quoi je
dirais qu'il ya une beaucoup d'argent à
déplacer des bouts de bois sur sur un
autre bout de bois
il faut s'habituer à avoir des caméras
quoi
tati faisait ivry caméraman pris fin
bien mais bon
c'est ton métier quoi
les esprits qu'eva
c'est comme ça ça fait partie du métier
voilà c'est gros plan dans son champ de
vision ne s'annonce pas trop le moment
je trouve
c'est ton métier tutu doit le gérer quoi
c'est pas y'a pas quelqu'un qui a allumé
un orchestre à côté quoi
déjà par là échec il n'y a pas de public
dans les salles il ya rien y'a personne
autour il ya un mec qui vient filmer
comme le silence au tie break
on va rester avec des échecs avec 500
vues sur twitter et des financements
très bizarre à vitam aeternam en fait
je leur lie a pas mort d'homme mais qui
avec sa caméra
il avec sa caméra
à
ils sont pas mis à chanter ou à parler
ou à faire quoi que ce soit
un spa une question de son lit rezaï le
fais tout le temps en fait ça c'est vrai
qu'il faudrait qu'ils s'habituent il est
jeune encore
mais bon
c'est comme ça
m
celle qui joue une partie père
importante pour sa carrière perso je le
comprendrais mais bon ils vont celui qui
gagne le tournoi et prend 100 mille
balles aussi deux chèques tu vois enfin
géré bout d'un moment peut pas tout
avoir dans la vie un
oui là c'est pas une position en plus où
il ya masse de calcul on peut importe
[Musique]
voir tourbe et six tours b 5
cet appui je confirme nul pour ses 5
c'est qu'en fait c'est quoi la défense
contre tours b si ce genre là je fais
tour b6 il fait quoi il fait tour c'est
non il fait ces trois là ok c'est 3 puis
on prend qu on prend et ça ça doit être
drôle
ouais ça ça doit être reçue d'accord 20
jeux l'accord avec sa fille le pion
angers 5e je crois pas que ce soit une
bonne nouvelle ils bloquent l'avancée
des pions blancs et ils empêchent la f4
et suroît j'ai trois tours ces deux à
cinq tours à deux tours à 6,3 g 7 ça ça
doit être nul
ouais il va arriva trop l'annulant
ailleurs
non mais surtout il a vraiment beaucoup
de drames avec dans les parties et il
fait des trucs pas très
normaux quand il en ait note qui
déconcentre vraiment l'adversaire aussi
donc bon
importe il est jeune on mais c'est sûr
il a 18 ans et ça s'arrangera mais il
faut apprendre quoi c'est la vie c'est
comme ça
il fait masse de drama à chaque fois
quoi
avec le bruit avec le machin en fait il
faut réussir en faire abstraction
surtout que c'est pas généralement c'est
pas un truc super dérangeant 1
ça traduit plus une free d'une fragilité
une nervosité de sa part qu'un réel des
rangements en fait
j'ai pas il fait tomber les pièces quand
il joue il a fait plein de fois contre
magnus touche les pièges sais pas il est
fait tomber parce qu'il tremble ça lui
arrive assez souvent
ce genre de chose qui arrive assez
souvent après ces deux là mais revisité
un c'est pas
c'est pas mal ou bien en fait c'est
juste ça traduit nervosité
ça se travaille de la sophrologie ou des
choses comme ça pour essayer de rester
plus calme
c'est pour réussir à cause de ça entre
guillemets qu'il avait fait l'erreur
incroyable dans la finale de roi avec
magnus et c'est juste une gestion de la
pression et la nervosité
mais c'est un problème narvik dont
parlait vlad ouais
je relate 40e coup nord avant de même ça
c'est ce qu'on faisait avant go vos
pâtes et maintenant ils le font plus ça
mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
t'attendais qui est noir et joué leur
coup pour partir parfois
jouer ton 41e et tu pars tu as après
donc la rúa g7
qu'est
ce siège je suis un vieux ouais nan là
dessus et un vieux gobbo la città un
vieux à l'ancien
service qui a racheté le non non non ça
se rajoutent automatiquement sur la
pendule
ils nagent avec des pendules mécanique à
re souvent je mange beaucoup joué avec
des pelles mécaniques marrant les pendus
mécanique
mais oui en fait la nervosité ça traduit
le fait qu'il ait en pas très sûr de son
jeu en finale aussi un
trouver 4 a quitté à jusqu'à 3-3 en fait
tomber quatre affaires tour à quatre
voitures immédiatement tour à 3par dont
il va immédiatement bloqué et ça c'est
nul déjà si la tour et de côté je pense
que ça c'est complètement d'euros
il ya encore des chances de gain oui il
ya des chances de gains mais
n'a guère qui a fait une énorme défense
ça montre le vrai débat mécaniquement
tournoi ah bah oui il y avait plus de
bruit à l'époque des pendules mécanique
arthur d'ailleurs en parlant du bruit
moi quand j'étais gamin et qu'on joue et
la plupart des tours à ces tampons d'une
mécanique et avait le bruit des pendules
non-stop
battu gérer quoi tu étais pas là à jeter
des pendus en dix ans
la pendule homogène quoi
je frappais comme un taré pour fly est
ce trop plein meeting ça va non non ça
servait 6,2 milliards ça ça c'est une
légende qui dit que taper fort sur la
pendule mécanique ne servait pas ça
servait vraiment
moment ça marche est vraiment ce truc là
un vrai réduit et c'est différent c'est
pas un bruit régulier puisque tu allais
quand acompte appuyé sur la pendule et
tout ça ça fait des changements de
rythme
le droit au casse continue tu as le
droit des boules quiès si tu veux ouais
ça changeait quoi taper fort sur la
pendule barre à l'époque des pendules
mécanique ça permettait donc lancé le le
mécanisme un petit peu plus rapidement
et ça faisait perdre un peu de temps à
l'adversaire
les gens de l'afrique pour pas qu'on
détruise le matériel mais c'est
tellement ça c'est une légende de que ça
changeait rien c'était pour pas qu'on
tape fort sur les pendules pour pas les
casser en fait
mais du coup
ouais ce serait maxime qui passeraient
devant alireza en termes de chances de
gain du tournoi parce que ça ferait deux
occases raté consécutifs de la part d'
ali reza et ça ça fait mal à la téte as
surtout qu'on voit qui commence à être
nerveux
attention ça pourrait coûter cher plus
tard dans le tournoi
surtout que maxime avec les blancs il
rate pas les joueurs comme nayais
si maxime du coup c'est plutôt du méga
résultat aujourd'hui encore surtout qui
s'est évité une fatigue ils firent
tellement bien son tournoi maxima on
sent que il a changé de dimension depuis
sa qualification aux candidats c'est
tournoi en jeu il est géré beaucoup
mieux qu'avant
tahri candidats je me rase la tête après
il n'ira pas
dans maximy gère le tournoi ça qui est
magnifique de sa part
monde sont à quitte à perdre demain
normalement tu ces trucs là tu peux pas
en fait on va voir quelle cet avis prend
là en gros un set-up que tu peux essayer
normalement c'est celui de la tournée en
a trois
mon tour à 8 h 5
moi j'ai un tour à deux en fait je fais
déjà vice et
les quatre à ggf 6 à 6
et tu peux essayer
là ils menacent ton pions donc du coup
tu peux tenter de faire fait tu aimerais
bien monter ton roi mais tu vas te faire
prendre et il va revenir il aura le
contre je et si tu pousses le pion en
fait il va attendre
ça ça peut gagner peut-être
au nom sera pas gagné ça
ça c'est drôle et tu t'approches il fait
les échecs
je peux pas ça c'est drôle
voitures etc sont par exemple propre
tour mares tu fais pas on revient
beaucoup plus bas et du coup tu essayes
de laisser en a 6 pour réussir à passer
le rang à 7 du coup les noirs vont
prendre à froid ils vont revenir
ça va pas gagner et l'autre technique de
gains ce serait d'essayer de jouer à six
et de garder une tour latéral ce qui
peut être ici est la meilleure chance
bizarrement généralement on déconseille
fatigué mais j'ai jamais dit ça en fait
un fou
donc en fait j'ai l'impression que les
deux ça tape sur défense maximum doivent
être après je peux tenter un tas de
marloux tri à base de hache quattro à
base de changement de structure de pions
pour essayer de rentrer dans un truc qui
gagne
80 80 salles avec à 6 du coût
mais normalement ça c'est toujours nul
mais ça peut être sûr à défendre
depuis sa crise et donc chaque pense que
j'ai parlé de la prochaine édition
c'est possible comme les vins
sa qualification candidat mais vu que
vu que la sara qualificatifs et s'est
pas fait et que andy a pris une autre
dimension depuis sa qualification
candidat tu comprends que c'est paille
s'est pas qualifié aujourd'hui en fait
on comprend que c'est
le dernier tourner les derniers
candidats en fait
lors dudit plus de 1m et je crois que
c'est drôle
je pense et draw et d'ailleurs
généralement ces finales quand ça reste
à plus de à des grosses profondeur c'est
que c'est drôle je le redis qui comprend
pas
mais geof qui sauve sa peau deux fois et
mais il fera pas sa peau demain s'ils
jouent contre maxime
ouais mais ali reza ça semble
complexe
barras qui va lutter pour essayer de
gagner
je voulais voir tarim et harry c'est
incroyable quand ils jouent en plus haut
total en fait
jules thiam gelé sous le sous le clic
ça va faire nul aussi normalement
hutaree complète
vous dira fouet blue vs flow coin
et harry qui va revenir 1
je vais écrire à fab
qui à favre
je sais mais bon c'est jusqu'à
il joue à 26 secondes et 26 60 et y en a
un qui doit gagner quoi
et presque regagner ses couloirs et
c'est bien
par contre dans le chêne co va perdre
contre vite yougov
ça c'est moins cool à
part un pas peut-être gbagbo mais ça ça
nous change pas grand chose pour ça ne
change pas grand chose pour nous
tabata bail qui va faire nul contre il
ya neuf plutôt pas mal
on craque a fait ce qu'il a gagné il a
battu il a battu rhinite chioukh
ça c'est très très positif
ces gagnants le plan c'est roger un f-22
mais si je mets la torah 2
pas con si si en fait
je attente s'est tout récemment je pense
cette finale à trois contre deux nuls et
puis ce fut à son tour b 5 au pied ont
fait rage six ans
après on peut avoir les blancs les noirs
pardon c'est
comme ça
parce que ça c'est chiant déception
avant à 7
je pense pas
qu'on va venir en a deux et de toute
façon le temps qu'il aille là bas les
noirs auront le temps d'aller chercher
des pions de ce côté de l'échiquier ça
doit être nul ce truc
je suis d'accord que c'est un coup que
je regarderai moins très certainement
l'idée serait que sur annecy son passage
simple ça ça peut être gagnant de ce
qu'on fixe le roi sur le pian h 6
mai sur h4 le problème ça doit être l'on
prend vois je crois tourache quatre
tours à 4
j'ai mon téléphone qui sonne
ces numéros bizarre qu'ils m'appellent
organisme de formation organisme de
formation
jusqu'à temps sur chaise base 10 00 dans
presque toutes les variantes sens c'est
ok donc c'est que c'est drôle mais c'est
pas parce que c'est nul que ça va faire
nul
terrible
retour des huit tours v7 20 on se doute
que ça fait nul arias ton franc à six
direct
ouais
maxime sûr que c'est bien et j'avais
vraiment le maxi 1000 cher son tournoi
et comme vous l'avez dit un peu plus tôt
il fait un peu ce que fait fabiano que
fait un dépôt pardon
en vidéo cette partie fait pas je vais
voir avec fabien j'en sais rien
moi j'ai pas le temps d'analyser je fais
déjà beaucoup trop de choses des risques
à l'aréna 18h ou pas
je te jette un oeil
à 18 heures on va la rater
17 ans mais ils ont décalé
décalé de quoi elle a gardé à 19h01
ouais ça va durer on va on va regarder
ça encore à mon avis assez longtemps
en espérant qu'ils ali reza réussi à la
gagner mais je vois pas la partie duré
moins d'une heure voire même deux
la finale était peut-être nul call belle
défense de nayer
vraiment sorti une partie de haut niveau
en arrière aujourd'hui
ce qu'il est capable de la perdre non
perdre ça c'est impossible
mais je pense que
il a réussi à la défendre
ça peut durer vrai
parti 12h j'exagère peut-être un peu
mais à une heure way une et elle va
durer encore une heure
28 à la 10e place ray mais il va
continuer à chuter le tournant est
encore long
c'est drôle quand il sent riche ça abba
avec les blancs situe près stats être
quand même 15 20 % de chances de gain
vu à quel point c'est difficile de
gagner une partie tu va tenter mais
clairement firoud déjà
il en fait beaucoup ça il me fait un peu
penser à l'ats philippe au tour de
france il en fait beaucoup
pendant que maxime il en fait beaucoup
moins
et donc il y aura peut-être plus les
jambes maxime dans les parties les plus
importantes
ex'im là il est vraiment dans les
meilleures dispositions
syfy ruf nuls
[Musique]
zéro c'est même maxime qui va se
commencer à se mettre mieux dans la
course parce qu'il ya un monde où maxime
double les blancs et il ya un monde où
il ya l'iresa lui pourrait doubler les
noirs donc ils seraient à égalité dans
le tournoi et maxime aurait un shot pour
3 blanc un noir et à lire ezzor est un
choc pour 3 noir un blanc
beaucoup plus longue partie alireza
après il a raison c'est aussi les
parties et le ton a qu'une demande
et affable
montre petrossian dans un maximum d trop
sion il a gagné petrossian
les majors du management sont naturels
perf à 2003 elle a réussit mal joué à 7
et 3 2 quand
j'ai pas du tout suivi les résultats
sont
de 1300 s est un peu léger
je regardais par curiosité
ça va être compliqué à trouver
faroy g3 c'est le coût que j'attendais
il va sûrement y avoir
3 4
les masos un
relation entoure à 4 pour bloquer
les h4 et compagnie
bonjour
monde
de mazo aurait pas terrible à vrai dire
terrible amazonia pas très bien joué ça
arrive
mais bon c'est sur cette ronde donc ça
fait pas beaucoup de mouvements alé lô
j'ai encore mon téléphone c'est un truc
de je vais pas être content d'eux comme
on appelle de formation
c'est terrible
je me suis fait peloter aide par le
changement d adresse automatique
en fait mon adresse suivant les gps elle
peut être écrit en rue ou avenue
et il ya des gps du cou qui donne pas
l'adresse correcte
c'était pas l'urssaf malheureusement
j'aurais bien aimé par la l'urssaf en
cette journée
sur l'a43 fz8 leur wiimote urraca 3f
deux montées droite inquiète pas je te
fais retour échec va monter droit
j'étais ton pions déjà
est ok faut calculer mais
normalement ça doit être cool ça pour
les noirs
est il faut tenter ça
peut-être qu'il ya un monde là où on
gagne ok faut tenter c'est d'avoir ça
riboud
du coup peut-être fait rage 5 avec les
noirs pour gagner un temps et sur walf
d'avoir tour à 2 prendre et on aura un
tendre plus est sûre h4 g4
ok c'était un piège
ça c'est être un piège
orange met en avant les parties du
suisse us et paris font n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui c'était pas une très belle
journée honnêtement
les parties ont pas été
la partie de maxime était sympa pendant
un moment puis bon on avait quand même
vite compris que ce qui se passerait par
un grand chose et celle d'ali reza quand
on arrivait c'était assez sympa et
financé rentrer dans cette finale
à rallonge
je dirais qu'on n'a pas eu de très
belles parties aujourd'hui
les autres jours les parties était plus
animée
je trouve
en salle de maxime ce que je disais la
première heure le débat théorique et
tout était assez sympa
complexe complexe
ça dure ça dure ça dure ça dure
ces longues et même pour moi là c'est à
dire un peu long
complexe
ch 5 du coup on sent qu'il peut y avoir
un piège surtout rassure tour à quatre
mois
c'est vrai
peut être un piège
ça passe ça peut être un piège
pas
l'impression que nos
calculs
je verrai ça sur le site de la fédé mais
je sais pas j'ai trouvé un peu au hasard
même ça ça gagne parle comme ça ça peut
être dangereux
un piège que 4 800 turing qui est passé
ouais ça arrive un
les pièges ça arrive hein
grasset complexe
depuis ses 8 ans ça je suis d'accord
avec toi mais c'est pas le gars tu
t'attends pas à ce qu'il la rate celle
là
quelle horreur
cette partie
r
ils savent que c'est drôle oui bien sûr
ils savent que c'est drôle ça tout le
monde sait que c'est enfin tout le monde
sait que c'est drôle
mais moi je sais on sait mais c'est
juste que tu sais que tu peux la gagner
ou à perdre
mes questions là c'est pas est ce que
c'est drôle ou pas c'est de savoir
concrètement comment tu fais
ça s'est passé en juin le problème c'est
les rajouts à hyper long 1
complexe
pierre que fin du tabac ici c'était
imbuvable truck ra ble ssé la même en
fait
aux candidats je sais pas en fait il ya
un système bizarre c'est que les
cadences khalid et aura qualificatif
aux candidats ne sont pas forcément
les mêmes que pour le tournage est
candidat lui même
j'ai pas des cas dans la cadence des
prochains candidats je la connais pas
forcément mais c'est pas la même cadence
ici que pour la coupe du monde qui est
un autre tour en qualifications
h pourquoi
voilà je est plus qu à vous dire les
amis
du coup est ce que les calmer as offert
une grosse plus-value ou pas
est ce que ça va faire une grosse
plus-value
tu coupes le live après
j'aurais bien voulu jouer la reina mais
je n'aurai pas le temps et puis vraiment
très fatigué en fait
ça va devant les sardes mvl ouailles
c'est cool hein
puis samuel avait pressé adversaires
avec le temps à
c'est ce qu'on est en train de voir là
c'est la raison ultime pour laquelle les
échecs marcheront jamais en fait c'est
tu peux pas garder des cadences comme ça
on peut meublé tu peux ce prix mais tu
peux faire ce que tu
vas tu peux faire
beaucoup mais il ya un moment donné où
tu peux pas en fait
c'est pas les sens pendant trop
longtemps
en en arrière
dans l'immédiat pas vraiment de mauvais
coups
ça vient science
c'est
[Musique]
c'est épuisant en fait à un moment donné
tu sais plus rien à dire en fait la
finale et les nuls théorique je vous ai
montré pourquoi je vous ai montré une
variante de comment ça peut mal tourner
après c'est aux joueurs de jouer les
coups et voir comment ça tourne en fait
on sait pourquoi c'est nul
on sait comment on peut essayer de
gagner
parler du coup c'est ma livraison qui
arrivait
c'est cool je forme est une [ __ ]
livraison d'
bah du coup survient avec micha
et oui mais oui mais oui
tourrades
alors mise 3 2 tandis qu à toi
elle veut repartir elle veut pas du tout
rester elle n'est pas du tout elle n'est
pas du tout intéressé par cette partie
je vous le dis tout de suite la partie
ne l'intéresse pas eu tour à deux
donc la paroisse g katia tour plonger 2
ça a l'air d'être bien drôle aussi bon
allez je vais je vais ressortir michard
elle a pris une balle du
3 2 c'est vrai que c'est pas mal aussi
dix tours ccid en chat web et il va
faire h61
tombés ici savent six tombes et 7,3 ici
à cette f 5 ça c'est droit aussi un
l a vu là l'équipe a mais elle est
restée une minute à leurs parts va même
pas une minute elle est venue à la
regarde elle est repartie
k
apparemment il n'y a pas moyen et f4 du
coup f4 h4h 4 cgh fois pour un tour
prend et f4 pareil ouais je crois que
c'est vraiment drôle rotours à deux
c'est pas mal joué aussi h5 c'était une
option toujours 1,4 c était une autre
mais tour à 200 pêche 3f de en plus
c'est vraiment bien joué
c'est drôle rossa
ça c'est drôle rond
c'est drôle roache d'euros d'euros
retient quoi c'est tout ranger deux
échecs
au
final on sait qu'elles sont d'une
théorie calculé quand tu les joues tu
trouves
ces transports en commun
salut bonjour afp les transports en
commun
il a manqué quelque part fille rousse
était nul
difficile de répondre à cette question
mais
clairement il aurait pu presser d'une
meilleure manière pour la gagne et ça
c'est sûr après ce que sur un jeu d'ordi
c'est toujours resté nul c'est aussi
possible
sur 3g capteurs prend au f5 oui mais la
justice
et on repart avec l'atout rade
donc ouais
ça va marcher
je sais pas si enfin il fondamentalement
c'était un truc défendable mais je pense
pas et de toute façon il y avait moyen
de mettre plus de pression et gagner
il va jouer juste assez longtemps pour
nous faire rater l'aréna magnifique
et clairement ses deux petits ratés
peuvent coûter plus tard dans le tournoi
parce que il aurait pu être à 6 sur 7 en
ayant joué exactement les mêmes
adversaires là il va être à cinq et il
va être à portée de fusil de tout le
monde donc s'il craque nerveusement sur
une partie fragile nerveusement il
il peut exploser
forcément loupé une manière de faire
déjouer nayer ça c'est sûr
mais là où il doit être dégoûté en plus
du coup il n'a pas la lucidité peut-être
comme vous le dites dans le chat et
c'est normal qu'il est par ailleurs
exactement la même réaction que lui mais
du coup il perd encore du temps sur
l'échiquier on est déjà
50 minutes s'il va peut-être passer 1h30
2h là dessus au lieu de retourner se
reposer pense à demain et il suffit de
tomber contre un et scipione cas où un
joueur comme ça avec les noirs et il
peut se faire taper et il aura tout
perdu
et s'y tiennent qu'à qui
lui aussi va faire un nul ça cedro
théorique
et ça laisse encore un espoir caruana de
remonter
et harris qui réussit à terminer le taf
à nantes harry qui va pas gagner alors
dit de ne plus gagnant je n'analyse pas
vraiment parce que pas le temps
mais le plot va piloter
ça va aller joueurs qui sont devant
garde
[Musique]
garde la distance
mais ça fait largement les affaires de
maxime qui peut peut-être taper un
joueur vraiment à sa portée de main avec
les blancs et un peu s'envoler quoi
ça fait
sim ça fait affaire de karwan à tout ça
et si rogers en fait c'est vraiment il
aurait battu shirov stéroïdes même
apparemment il va aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
il a exactement les mêmes appariement le
même tournoi il a 6 sur 7 6 sur 7 il est
déjà quasi qualif la 5 sur 7 il cravache
quoi
il a fait 4
jf il va faire froid f3 imagine
ce qui aura presque quatre tours angers
de joie pas dans quel monde ça gagne
et salue center
ces attaques c'est vrai je pense ça
toujours été nul n'est en tout cas moi
quand je suis passé c'était nul
théorique après avec les ordis vous
pouvez avoir l'impression que ça va être
gagnant mais ça donnait plus 2 mais
c'était nul
sa pensée qui sert raté mais ces milles
théoriques
vient longtemps
jeu s'étant remis les turbines est pas
assez fort même les grosses turbines
peuvent se tromper ex
alors est ce qu on suit ça jusqu'au bout
est-ce qu'on tente de jouer la reina on
va voir
bien jouer j'en sais rien après je peux
jouer une demi heure une heure et voir
ce que ça donne
pour angers 2 je vois pas dans quel
monde c'est pas juste des taureaux
a life il le pion g2 je sais même pas ce
qu'il veut tenter en fait
qui est tu peux tenter roy e st croix
d63 machin roi bessette mais les noirs
ont le contre je
enfin faites là je comprends même pas à
l'idée de gain en fait 2 0 déjà
tourbes et huit tours à deux tours à
huit c'est un truc qu'on aurait pu on
aurait pu avoir la même mais avec le
avec un pion de plus quoi
prochain jeu maxime c'est demain à 13
heures
non non la finale nuls depuis un moment
ça c'est sûr
mais là c'est vraiment faim tour ado je
comprends je n'arrive même pas à
comprendre l'idée de gain en fait
5 mais bon il va juste pas joué tu te
mets là même englouti fait nul à nice
puis mais le bus 30 secondes par coup il
fait drôle 5,3 de trucs qui veut ces
rois des six
f5
roi c'est cette f4 roi bsf trois
tours b 1 il veut ça
bref si ce tour f1
f2 à 7 ans elle veut ça en gros
et sur quoi tu peux faire tomber deux
échecs d'abord
roi à 8 et ben non f2 à cette étude
montrent le roi
malki calcul mais je veux dire à
l'intuition c'est tous les coups logique
après tu calcules je dis pas que c'est
pas normal qu'ils réfléchissent pas
attention hein mais je veux juste dire
qu'on va être les coûts évident font nul
parce que çà çà çà çà
çà çà c'est hyper logique et là l'idée
c'est que c'était un peu coupé
sur a7 f2 tour b 1 ok il veut tenter ça
et à vrai dire moi j'ai 6 du coût à huit
dames pour prendre on apprend
roitg cinq tours f1 roi h quatre tours
f2 roi je croyais peut-être que même ça
c'est nul
il va trouver il va chercher un truc
plus clean et est qu'il a rien d'autre
on va voir
peut-être dans cet ordre là
jamais peut-être tour f1 vous dites
dans la tourbe et deux
à huit dames
on voit prend rage et cinq
toiles fait un rush 4
ça c'est drôle
bref c'est un café un ancien roi g4 et
h5
diffusion à waimes là c'est mort à la
partie jour un peu dans mon jeu la
suivent les français
fait un peu ken 1 mais non je
n'arriverai pas à la joue et l'aréna
ça
parce que j'aimerais bien bien la jouer
mais là j'y arriverai pas rester sur
ça c'est sûr
malheureusement il n'y a pas de monde
l'ajout c'est terrible quand même
c'est un peu robert toi t'as fait ça
serait plus marrant jouer contre
ouvertement
ses comptes jusqu'à 19h en fait j'aurais
eu le temps
un sage us 80% on peut trouver à refaire
un sondage mais
mais ça changera pas grand chose après
je fais un peu ce que je veux mais bon
normalement on est censé suivre jusqu'à
la fin des joueurs français même si ça
n'a aucun intérêt
il peut encore se passer un truc en fait
2 c'est dans cette partie peut encore se
passer quelque chose
il peut encore se passer un truc
même si
on se fait chier très largement
en fait le truc en plus les gens qui
sont là ils veulent encore suffire au
delà donc forcément il ya une plus
personne qui va tient plus personne en
fait
c'est s'est largement trop long
et
juste à se passe plus grand chose
mais c'est pas la faute des joueurs ou
quoi c'est vraiment la cadence là
c'est vraiment cadence le problème ça tu
peux pas avoir des trucs qui durera près
les ait note encore
des heures
et ambitieux de assiste aussi historique
à sa gagnerez peut-être avec le plan b
si si si
jusqu'à maintenant on a eu du bol on n'a
pas eu de partie pour ave comme ça
et nous on sait comment faire nul dans
la partie il peut de choc il peut il
peut se tromper encore c'est pas à le
comment dire les coûts à venir sont
intéressants c'est juste que si ça a
duré 20 minutes à partir de maintenant
ce serait super ou même au partir de là
début de la finale ce serait vraiment
bien le truc c'est qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de chance qu'on passante ou 2h
2h30 sur un truc avec 90% de chance deux
nuls et où les variantes face et soit il
trouve soit il trouve pas
à vrai dire en tout cas celle qu'on a
montrées fait nul
fréquence qui ont essayé 40 minutes
ajouté ouais mais ça fait partie de la
cadence en réalité la cadence coupe du
monde au lieu de 50 minutes a ajouté je
crois qu'ils en ajouter 25 et du coup là
on aurait déjà terminé la partie donc ça
aurait été bien
d'ailleurs fatigué qui arrive peut-être
pas calculé jusqu'au bout
enfin possible retour aura pu parce que
j'ai montré avec le pion h et c'était
nul laval aberrantes et complètement
forcé fait s'ils rentrent dedans tous
les coups sont forcé tour adle de toute
façon ton plan c monte avec le roi f5
soissons tu montes trompions roi c'est
cette f4 or la l'ordi pense que c'est
gagnant après rouabeh 8 alors attendez
tête je me suis planté f3 à cette sève
de tourbe et un
3g si ce nom alors dit comprend
maintenant que c'est nul
à huit dames alors dit a mis du temps à
comprendre ça c'est nul
et drôle
qu'ils se trompent mais ça c'est drôle
et h 5 h 4g 2h 3h 2 h 1
cette variante elle est très linéaire
est très fort c'est
avant la phase 5
est drôle
si c'est forcément qu'ils trouvent il
faut qu'il soit sûr
le truc c'est que c'est tous les coups
les plus logiques
alors honnêtement les le le truc alors
c'est pas toujours le cas mais là c'est
les coupes torrejon en bullet la torah
deux qui part
fait là le problème c'est que la
variante allait pas dur en fait moi je
l'envoyais par hasard et vous disais la
turbine elle trouve pense que c'est
gagnant au début pour les blancs mais
c'est tous les coups les plus logique
pour les deux joueurs en fait
évidemment quand tu joues en partie tu
vérifies
c'est tout à fait normal c'est comme je
vous disais c'est la cadence qui fait
que c'est si long
je pense qu'on va avoir trop de retard
non à 10 minutes de retard wayne on va
se faire
on va se faire kane a déjà trop de
retard à ses bêtes
ces bêtes qu'ils aient
maintenu cette heure
pas vraiment qui finissent dans les
quatre cinq minutes quoi mais sa rage ou
encore un quart d'heure
aucun intérêt
ali reza easy qui peut se tromper mais
là il va encore nous réfléchirons hall
attendent encore pour 15 20 minutes
minimum en vrai
je vois trop expliqué en fait tu sais
les goûts que tu vas jouer mais tu
vérifies tu prends ton temps
clairement les joueurs jouent des coups
mais s'arrête comme je vous dis ça pas
grand intérêt quoi
c'est pas pensé pour le public les
joueurs ouais bon enfin s'en foutent en
vrai
teri pa fait on rajoute on savait que
c'était drôle
façon ça comme je le disais tout à
l'heure
ex now ces finales lan ailleurs pour
qu'il la perde son but c'est pas le
profil à perdre ce à quoi
on avait dix mille personnes à quelques
huîtres est passé
on a si c'est pire que rien pour les
échecs
c'est exactement ce qui ne devrait plus
exister qui existent encore et qui
permet à ce que les les buzz
systématique des échecs meurt en fait
parce que ils font des cadences qui sont
d'un autre âge et qui ce qui qui ne
favorise même pas finalement le la
qualité du jeu en fait
disons que là on est vraiment sur
quelque chose qui nuit au spectacle sans
forcément améliorer le jeu
ces gars qui fait tourner en général
manquant contraire être plus en plus de
monde lundi on était on est monté
jusqu'à 7500 quand même constat après
quatre heures de jeu aujourd'hui avait
moins de monde après ya plus de monde
quand je fais sur ma chaîne bien
bizarrement ou pas d'ailleurs
ouais mais là elle est vraiment trop
longue cette cale ans
salah les trop longues
ça de la coupe du monde elle était
beaucoup mieux avec le 25 minutes de
rajouts
ça change absolument rien la qualité de
jeu quasiment rien ça change une partie
sur 100 mais ça nuit tellement au
spectacle
pour r
même l'asim coach idoine en sallaz c'est
la pire
là ils font fait ils ont ils ont tous
les coups tous les coups que je vous ai
donné tout à l'heure
à tempo ils les ont en fait
les joueurs
fait à vendre que je vous ai montré il
était car j'ai regardé l'heure ils
étaient 53 quand je voulais montrer les
deux joueurs l'avc sur est juste pour la
jouer ça va durer trente quarante
minutes
les pots cassés un certain temps car on
sera la même que celle là
c'est surtout que les échecs c'est pas
censé être un spectacle et plaire à la
masse et le contraire du show accessible
bon ailleurs il a tout trouvé en fait il
a tout vu l'aï s'élevait à bruges pas
d'accord on est comme avoir de belles
audiences sur twitter quand même
beaucoup de gens qui suivent les échecs
et qui aime bien les échecs et qui
s'ennuie à fort st
robe blanc retourne vers le pion f ben
tura 5 1
se passe rien quoi
avec un jeu denver était sympa ouais
c'est intéressant
mais oui les parties devraient durer
cinq heures maximum en fait cinq heures
ça devrait être genre le max de max pour
les longues
vraiment la cadence coupe du monde
au lieu de mettre 50 minutes et d'en
remettre 15 tu mets une fois à 25 et
peut-être une fois 10 au 60e si tu as
vraiment envie
et là la partie serait déjà fini depuis
une demi-heure avec le même résultat les
mêmes coûts en plus
le ban de samuel etienne tafer chez aba
oui mais bon il a pris le raid maudit
aussi samuel etienne terrible
je suis avoir pu jouer
je suis quand même dingue ne pas avoir
pu jouer
j'ai vu qu à dire
ça dégoûte
leur ajoutant à chaque coup ça existait
sur the mechanic un an
assad et en plus exactement à ce que
j'ai montré à 30 minutes je suis dégoûté
je suis dégoûté
de toute façon maintenant que je parte
ou pas j'ai raté le tournoi j'ai raté ma
life un
terrible
bon apparemment pour mv louey sylla les
blancs samba d'appariement
on
le vrai risque c'est marrant moi ça a
dit mitch et entraîneur pas vraiment
c'est juste que les semaines de
commentaires de ton est reparti ce fait
c'est twitter d'analystes par jour tous
les jours
avec le déménagement à côté le machin le
truc c'est un peu le moment détente tu
vois c'est le moment où ça fait un peu
plus de stream tu vois des parties tube
it's un peu c'est cool c'était histoire
de passer un bon moment en fait c'est
plus ça
tu vas c'est tous les jours comme ceux
qui bossent tous les jours 10 heures ça
comme j'ai le déménagement et tout s'est
vraiment pas une bonne période
donc
tu as juste envie de te faire place deux
heures dans la semaine quoi là c'est
puis surtout que ce n'est pas
intéressant en fait ce qu'on voit ça qui
est relou
je pense pas que une finale intéressante
la salle assez vraiment linéairement ce
qu'on a vu c'est sûr que ça va jouer ce
que tous les coups
sûrs de ouais mais je crois que c'est
drôle après peut-être je me trompe pas
fait c'est drôle peut-être un truc qu'on
a ratées mais bien sous que la ligne
absolument forcé de a à z
c'est ça qui est frustrant en fait à 17h
tu sais que c'est drôle à 17h50 qui
connaît tous les coups de la partie
rev7 pourra c'est tout racisme a en fait
je manque un tempo pour faire ça je fais
tour à 6,6 à tour franck tour apprend et
f1 dame
chômage ou la reine 1.23 je pense qu'il
s'en fout complètement du tournoi
je vous pose qui joue quoi france
avec
de chants s'élevaient à l'expo sur ce
tournage c'est pas dur à dire faut que
je voie les autres résultats
il a fait comment il a fait froid berry
temps il va faire les lignes 3bis 8
9 3 f 2 ça apprendra 8 ça va monter
du coup là
est
rev 2
torbey un mois j'ai ici cela c'est sûr
qu'ils ont la ligne jusqu'au bout
pas en utiliser c'est un ils n'ont pas
non il s'embarquait dans cette finale
jusqu'au bout un
scan magnifique d'avoir matin il fait
tomber cette
non il a fait à cette part dont on rêve
de tomber cette c'était bizarre
ce truc qui fait plaisir c'est que c'est
que j'ai montré la ligne
jusqu'au bout
que c'est drôle ouais ils savent que
c'est drôle depuis depuis la fin du dix
ait à
16h50
depuis 16h50 les deux savent que c'est
nul théorique après nayar lui il a dû
rester très vigilants pour pas rater
mais les deux savent que la position est
théoriquement nul
g6
peut-on t ah non il peut il n'y a pas de
patente et pourrait faire tomber le
dommage en fait ouais ça on l'avait vu
déjà
faire des bijoux inscrits alors tu as
peut-être 10% de chances de gagner ou 5
avec les blancs ont 15 je sais pas en
fait je crois ne pas jouer quand tu as
une chance de gain j'arrive pas à
comprendre qu'on vous comprenez pas ça
en fait
juste une petite chance mais à
plat ça se voit que firent oui c'est que
c'est drôle
même tombé de fait drôle à tomber ne
l'aurais pas fait quand même
à même magnifique tour b 2 peut-être non
je n'aurais jamais fait tomber de f1 et
la tourbe et cet échec intermédiaire
ah mais ça c'est drôle comme sa foi
ouais même même tombé de fées d'euros
ouais c'est pour dire elle a vraiment
tout fait drôle à
hem tourbe et de fait d'euros
non mais je n'aurais jamais fait
ce que tu peux attendre mais tu peux te
faire contrer comme
ça j'aurais jamais risqué qu'annoncé non
mais ça tu vas jamais rentrer là dedans
tu sais jamais ça
il se trouve que l'ordi donneront aussi
dans ma fille 3b cette
dame g7 et ça il se trouve que c'est
drôle alors je sais pas comment on a
fait pour faire drôle dans toutes les
lignes
mais tu d'avoir trop de problèmes avec
tadam
donc même ça fait nul
mais bon le plus simple c'est ce que
j'ai montré un roi j'ai six à huit dames
pour prendre on apprend roi g5 il faut
bien que la torah et chercher le pion
roi h43 prend et après on en voit le
pion et la tour sera obligée de se
sacrifier le roi blanc est trop loin
pas réussi à gagner terrible plaute aide
mais navarre gagner pourrait jouer
contre maxime demain navarra du coup
comme tu vas pas de match nul ou
terrible
hier qui a perdu contre fedoseyev
on a je sais pas je sais pas ce qu'ils
ratent
c'est parce qu'ils ratent
aucune idée
maxime a fait drôle
il sait que c'est nul mais il traîne
quoi
il est à la variante ans elle est
vraiment primitive
pour aujourd'hui mais firoud déjà
aujourd'hui le truc c'est que ça fait
deux parties en comme on le disait où il
a eu un grand avantage contre des
joueurs plus faibles et qui les a ratées
et du coup ça peut ça peut
entamer sa confiance
et devenir un petit grain de grain de
sable dans la machine
à l'avant ça l'est vraiment faim leaf
vous s'assure que la variante quand je
les regardais la première fois
exactement celle là celle que j'ai
regardé 100 turbines j'ai juste mis les
coûts qui me paraissait le plus logique
alors évidemment je me répète mais quand
on calcule en partie on doit regarder
beaucoup plus de variantes pour être
bien sûr et c'est normal
mais
mais ça veut dire que c'est pas enfin
c'est à dire du tout en fait c'est les
coupes tu regarde en premier qui sont
les bons
james hunt qu
il ya peut-être de nouveau gagner
je vois pas de risque de blender non je
vois pas en fait le danger prime c'est
un truc qui m'échappe mais je vois pas
le danger
dieu je vois pas où est le problème
ce qu'il a peur que ça ça gagne pas que
ça pardon
ce soit nul
que ce soit pas nulle part dont
pas là ça me dépasse
après j'avais annoncé à 16h50 entre une
et deux heures de jeu
jusque 2 plutôt de kuhn donc ils veulent
me donner raison
ils prennent surtout ray fin à van damme
c'est qui la tourbe et deux
échecs leroy décalé on revient
c'est
pas vraiment
c'est vrai j'avais dit deux heures je
croyais pas mais j'ai l'expérience de la
cadence un
minimum une heure est plutôt de kuhn
peuvent pas voir l'afrique qui
s'embrouillent c'est possible
bon avec les blancs j'aurais pas proposé
nul ans j'aurais joué comme ali reza
enfin je paye soit gelée même coup mais
je leur ai joué pareil
en vrai s'ils annulent me paraissait pas
si évidente fin je vois pas comment on
peut se tromper en fait c'est juste tous
les coups normaux si ce n'était pas le
cas j'aurais espoir
peut-être que d'ailleurs a raté un truc
et qui va et qui va nous faire plaisir
un qui sait
ça me paraît incroyable
il a un fantôme quelque part et il ne
sait pas quand il est rentré la dent
j'étais persuadé qu'ils avaient tous
jusqu'au bout
d'un long tube l'année après être
retourné le cerveau à réfléchir à des
coups à la con qu'un sas pression ça
peut lui dans le règne des 5 10% de
chances de gain forcément c'est que des
hallucinations la salle elle me paraît
impossible à avoir mais
plus nayar réfléchis plus je me dis que
ça peut arriver 1
très surpris ya honnêtement dont ils
envoyaient f2 j'ai pensé croisés si
c'est tout ça arriverait très vite ça je
suis extrêmement surpris
il rajoute quinze minutes au 60e et
encore
ça peut le show qui c'est vrai qu'on
joue bien ça me paraît absolument
hallucinant mais
c'est vrai que la réflexion sur ce coup
là est très étonnante
et son langage corporel n'est pas très
positif
fait nul aussi c'est ce qui m'inquiète
le plus mais j'ai l'impression qu'ils
les parties calculées tourbe et deux
échecs se fout
le problème c'est que même ça ça marche
voire 60 ce qu'on peut faire c'est
attendre la cessoie il joue le truc
hyper logique et ça va
soyez gaffe mais
y'a qu'à attendre
pas donc on y la gagne pas
il fait en effet pas nul mais
r d'autres
hier de stresser pour air d'ailleurs
mais aussi parfois avec l'âge on se met
à stresser un peu plus
étonnamment
jalil a tout vu un
il attend là
toute façon s'il fait froid j'ai ici
sera obligé de faire dame en fait les
coups de fil rouge à ils sont
complètement forcé
faut être fou pour calquer tourbe et je
suis d'accord avec toi robbins aïn melha
honnêtement
je me répéter et j'imagine que tu
écoutes mais enfin franchement la
variante qui l'envoie c'est
dame
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
ah mais
incroyable
c'est tourcoing f1
tourbe et de
rien compris c'est peut-être trop quand
même
non mais c'était trop aussi c'est
incroyable ça ça c'est incroyable
ça c'est peut-être le cadeau bon on aura
bien fait d'attendre
incroyable c'est vrai c'est quand on
vous parle des trucs où ça gagne jamais
oui c'est toujours nul parce qu'il ya
des fois il arrive ce genre de merde
ou alors est ce que c'est drôle ou pas
c'est un sable absolument incroyable
mais comment ça en fait ça la question
je comprends par la visuellement façon
s'il l'a fait c'est que c'est pas si con
c'est incroyable quand même ne pas avoir
joué le truc le plus logique mais
c'était quand même très logique je
comprends pas
ça s'est il n'y a rien de plus linéaire
que cette [ __ ] de variantes quand même
là c'était tombé de l'échec quoi donc
c'était à huit dames d'abord de toute
façon si après ça suroît g6 le coup
c'est tour f1 autant avoir gardé le plus
envie
donc c'était à huit dames dont 8 3.183
g5
ok mais c'était vraiment complètement
forcé en fait
et tu pousses tombions c'est hyper fort
c'est en fait tu comprends pas
je comprends pas en fait
ehpaddes aides
à ça c'est étonnant alors là c'est au
moment où on s'y attendait le moins
quand même un nom c'est quoi
attendez attendez temps il faut encore
un peu de précision
pour ses 1
tourcoing h3
pour ces sept
mois g63 b8 ça ça va pas mais là il ya
tour c63 bessette sa gagne donc ces rois
g8 forcé roy b8 touriste y ait
complètement gagnant sa série 8 dames le
roi est coupée c'est terminé oui mais
c'est vrai que mon père me mais en fait
c'est un safin truc tu veux ça et ça
hein
facile en plus
c'est tour c'est indirect à 3 tours
c'est cette
suroît g6 et tour c63 mon trajet 7 et on
couvre et ça gagne
je sais que chaque rallye d'espagne oui
aujourd'hui je leur ai joué avec les
blancs pareil hein
après moi ce que je comprenais pas c'est
ce que foutent est d'ailleurs sur tout
mais c'est incroyable ça
mais ça se voyait qu'il y avait un truc
qui n'allait pas à la fin pour lui
c'était tellement bizarre parce qu'il a
joué tous les tous les coups logique
d'ailleurs et c'était vraiment facile à
la fin
ça peut faire une grosse 10pour la
qualif 1 pour ali reza donc c'est un
super résultat juste c'est un peu c'est
très étonnant mais voyez c'est la
différence entre le top top niveau et
les amateurs quoi d'ailleurs pour moi
c'est un joueur quand même qui est plus
dans le règne tout qu'il devrait être
dans le règne amateurs pour un sport
individuel et leïla a le niveau pour
être pro quoi pas assez fort et là on le
voit ça illustre bien la serrant le ce
match hyper facile que tu mets dehors
avec le temps ils n'étaient pas les
rares paradoxalement chez pai s'est pris
la tête
mais la voilà par exemple les cas m'ont
vraiment servi parce que on l'a vu dans
le langage corporel qui avait quelque
chose qui n'allait pas mais c'est un
incompréhensible en fait c'est la
fatigue ouais mais d'ailleurs il est
plus tout jeune il a quel âge
alors attendez jouve le nikki wikipedia
nayyar fb init
vignerie wittchen ailleurs né en 1960
1977 est acceptée en ehpad en 2020
depuis ce temps il a un petit peu des
problèmes pour terminer ces partis
apparemment
complexe
complexe complexe
et ouais non 44 ans mais c'est normal
enfin aux échecs
c'est un gars sympa en plus pour la
peine en plus je le connais en fait je
déjà vu plusieurs fois il est cool
mais pour la peine l'âge ça
ça ne nous arrange pas
la longue déclinaison la longue descente
44 ans et vieux pour les échecs avec 44
ans et vieux ouais
bon jour meiway vieux de
oka l'iresa trouve le gain ça a pas
l'air d'être gagné non plus
incroyable mais bon il faut la gagner
encore
fait tour c'est un tour c'est cette
c'est vraiment très fort
et le problème avec le pion h quand tu
monde sait que tu peux te faire coupe à
dos
3 à trouver mais tu as fait avec ordi
non non quand j'ai trouvé le truc la
première fois mais c'était hasarde
c'était juste la variante réflexe but
lettre que j'ai envoyée c'était la bonne
mais après
bol mais c'était première intuition bien
on qu'en première intuition marche suis
dit bon ils vont calculer ça marche
c'est un trouvé c'est assez facile en
fait
choquée mais non il est choquant beauté
c'est
arrivé c'est vraiment
l'hallucination 3g 6
ok
c'est pas fait encore
c'est pas dit gagne encore
h5 tôt bessette
proches ouah
ouah bay 8
voix ça ça peut être trop encore
eye en bessin quest ix ou coupons b5 ça
gagne
comme c'est un pur h on peut pas
contourner
est
ce qu'un tour ses six échecs 3g 5
ouais ça passe aussi h4
tout raciste ou rachète les droits sera
trop eliane et salia nï
100 en blitz est pas facile à gagner du
tout
à fait tour ses sept
tout reprend
wab et huit tours à trois
à huit dames ont comprises h 5 tours b /
g 5 c'est fini ça gagne là encore
ça gagne 2 partout en fait
il a tellement été en contresens a
d'ailleurs
assez surnom
le fn dame ça sans texte un coup de
chiottes 1 quand même
il a dû rater un truc con dans le truc
où tu montres leroy
expliquait il à il a dû
halluciner quelque part
voilà pourquoi j'irai jusqu'au bout mais
exactement baisse pour ça que avec les
blancs à lire et zag comme j'ai dit
plusieurs fois il avait aucun intérêt à
faire nul après pas normalement ça passe
jamais faim surtout dans la position
dans laquelle on est arrivés normalement
ça passe jamais mais ouais c'est le 5 %
de chances qu'ils passent un
après je pense à 27 50 c'est vraiment un
pour cent voire même 0,1 mais à ce
niveau là il ya vraiment peut-être 3 4 %
de chance et s'est passé surtout contre
un joueur âgé quand même je dois dire
contrats joueurs un peu un peu âgées en
milieu fans tournoi comme ça qui fatigue
ça peut rater après là c'est
vraiment incroyable
c'est un truc comme ça alors là c'est la
chance à
lacets de la chance et on en a besoin
il n'a pas spécialement bien pressé pas
spécialement mis un problème difficile
ou quoi vais aux échecs pour gagner une
partie de toute façon faut que
l'adversaire fasse des erreurs si ton
adversaire fait pas d'erreur tu gagneras
0 parti
en même temps en temps il faut un peu de
chance ça ça fait partie du jeu
la réussite
pousser son adversaire à l'erreur là son
adversaire un peu tombé tout seul mais
bon
on en la variante qu'on a vu avec la
tour qui vient b5 et c'est terminé
au japon la réussite le tas est en ce
moment il a un peu la baraka mai
mais ça fait partie du jeu hein
c'est fou de voir ça en franchise ouais
mais c'est aussi dû au surtout enfin en
1901 mais c'est dû aux nombreux nombreux
forfaits 1 là on a des joueurs qui
normalement devrait jamais être aussi
bien classés 1
5 3 bessette
à lui un coin ça se voit que la chance
était passée
c'est très bien joué
une position perdante et gagne ça là
après il ya des périodes dans la vie on
a plus de réussite plus de baraka des
par exemple en a moins en ce moment
c'est
ccl et pour pour ali reza la baraka et
c'est tant mieux la chance sourit aux
audacieux
beaucoup auraient proposé nul non non
personne n'aurait proposé nul tout le
monde aurait tenté comme fear où
certains de manière plus pénible que
d'autres pensent à magnus qui trouve
toujours des trucs d'un autre monde
mais on n'a rien aucun joueur de haut
niveau qui aurait fait nul dans la
position de fil rouge a
fait gagner un tour à 6
il arrive par dépit parce qu'il sait
qu'il a perdu un truc que tu doit jamais
perdre
mais maintenant c'est passé c'est 3d
s'être s'être fc3 g7
et à huit dames
voilà il sait que c'est perdu mais il
sait qu'il a raté nul est dégoûté
d'ailleurs
quel coup il a fait fin dame au 50e il a
fait un coup très étonnant
voilà il sait qu'il a perdu va
abandonner en fait là il essaye juste de
comprendre où il a raté la nulle l'aérés
d'ailleurs là il fait il fait ce visage
là ils cherchent même plus réfléchi plus
à la position qu'il a actuellement il
réfléchit à quel moment il a raté nul et
c'est terminé
mais voilà il est en train de lui dire
f1 dame et lui demande à quel moment
jarret j'ai raté nul et lui dit f1 il
est en train de lui montrer la ligne roi
g6 tu montres leroy et tu vas chercher
fait alireza il avait vu évidemment
elana your way
un état avec l'orangé 3 il est en train
de lui expliquer ouais il est en train
de montrer avec les doigts la variante
exceptionnel il lui a montré ça se
voyait il me montrait les cases et les
idées donc alireza il avait la balle
jeudi elle n'était pas très dur à
trouver un
elle était très très linéaire et n'avait
rien d'exceptionnel s'est vu que
d'ailleurs il a
il ay là il a un peu soufflot t
il à un peu saoul flotter et au moins on
sent qu'il avait raté un essai qu'il a
raté quelque chose de très simple il a
vu un fantôme il a il ya eu une
hallucination sais
c'est la fatigue beaucoup de calculs
partie longue partie trop longue pour
lui
et du coup on écoute et on va se quitter
sur une page de pub et on se retrouvera
demain à l'aréna mais on ne pourra pas
la jouer parce qu'on est à une heure de
retard ça fait trop et on se retrouvera
demain pour pour un autre hymne on fera
un after life avec fab demain
et du coup merci à tous d'avoir suivi
ciao ciao